first of all george pleasure to meet you
joe great to talk to you good great to
see you in person great to see you too
and jeremy good to see you again good to
see you this is uh
we're doing this often this is becoming
a thing uh george uh
i think that you're probably like one of
the most important figures when it comes
to journalism and ufos
and when you uh broke the bazaar story
was that is that 89 when was that
1989 89 1989 um
i remember reading about it i remember
hearing about it i remember watching
clips on television and watching
countless bob lazar interviews it all
came out of you i mean did you
think at that time what was your
thoughts about ufos before you had met
bob lazar
and how much did it change while you got
to know him and hear his story
it changed quite a bit i had not really
given it much thought at all
you know probably the same level of
curiosity as most people
you go about your life you pay your
bills you go to work you you love your
family
uh and it's always out there somewhere
hey i wonder what the deal is on that
but not
had not really dwelled on it until it
was a day in 1987
into the studio comes a guy named john
lear
and i had heard sort of a little bit
about him his family was famous his dad
developed the learjet the eight-track
tape
john had run for the state senate and he
had a certain amount of credibility with
our news organization
kla because he had helped us break a
really big story and the story was
the stealth fighter the f-117 he had
told my boss
ned day managing editor about this
amazing plane
that was invisible to radar flying up in
tonopah in area 51.
we had an interest in area 51 not ufo
related but
ned broke that story it went national so
john lear comes into the station one day
with a stack of what turned out to be
ufo documents he plops them on ned's
desk
and says ned this is going to be the
next big story the biggest story in
history it's a ufo cover-up
aliens are here technology's been
recovered ned takes a look at it and
says
i'm not doing this story if it was true
i'd already know know about it this is
crazy well i'm eavesdropping as i
tend to do i'm a curious person so
as he's going out i said lear let me
take a look at this material and i
looked at i thought well this is kind of
interesting
at the time i was producing and hosting
this little public affairs show
30-minute interview show
it would air sunday morning at six
o'clock nobody watches it it would be
interviewing a city councilman a county
commissioner what the heck i'll put lear
on there and i let him go
and he told me this big scenario about
secret treaties with aliens and
recovered technology and a giant
cover-up some of the information
sounded outrageous some of it seemed
like it would be worth checking out
suddenly the phone starts ringing off
the hook i'm getting calls about people
that
who was that guy what was the deal on
that ufo stuff is it real
i had him on again six months later the
response was bigger had him on a third
time
with a guy named bill cooper i regret
that
and he told him an even more elaborate
conspiracy he's the behold the pale
horse guy yes yeah i read that book and
halfway through i was like what in the
[ __ ] is this
yeah he tied in the jfk assassination
and everything
bases on the moon aliens are there right
now he had he had this scenario where
he had seen these documents when he was
in the navy and
he's going to tell the world about it
then he's going to go away well every
time he
he told the story the documents got
bigger and bigger and anybody who
criticized bill cooper
became part of the secret government
including me so we do this third
show with lear and he hints that he
knows a guy who might be going to work
out of dairy 51 and knows something
about alien technology that guy turns
out to be
bob lazar but lear didn't give me the
name at that time
a couple months later i am anchoring the
five o'clock news on klas
and uh we have a nightly or
evening uh interview segment five minute
segment live interview
our guest doesn't show up and we're
scrambling to find somebody to
to fill that hole and i thought about
lear so i called him up not knowing what
had been going on in lazar's life or
lear's life
and i said hey is your uh that ufo guy
you told me about is he around would he
do an interview
just turned out that bob had been
through the ringer a lot of stuff going
on in his life he felt threatened
and he said yes we had to black out his
face we do this interview and he spills
the basics of the story
i worked out there at a place called s4
i saw nine
flying saucers and an underground base
this is technology that came from
somewhere else i'm in fear for my life
holy cow the phones start ringing off
the hook my news director comes rushing
in the station manager is that for real
what's the deal on that
and we realized we had touched the pulse
of the public in a way that i didn't
really understand
we arranged to go meet bob lazar my news
director bob stollow and i
that following weekend and put him
through a paces where we would ask him
questions about his background and how
he got the job
we spent a couple hours with him and we
walked out of that meeting thinking
holy [ __ ] what if this is true um you
know this is
really risky for us as journalists it's
risky for
our personal reputations if it blows up
in our faces
and we do this story and it would really
damage the reputation of our news
organization which is
klas is a jewel it's always been a
leader in in las vegas
one of the best tv news operations in
the country we're putting a lot on the
line well look
we decide let's take our time let's look
into this guy's story
and then in order to understand lazar
we'd have to look at
the bigger picture of ufos so i started
a cram course
on ufology and i read everything and i
spent eight months like
cramming for a final exam that never
happened i read everything i
interviewed people that same year mufon
had its
its international symposium in las vegas
and there
all the world's ufo people came right to
me i got to interview him
traveled around went to los alamos uh
lazar took us into the lab
we took cameras in there he walked us
around waving
to people we didn't even have to stop
for security
took us into the the lab like it was a
rabbit going through its own burrow he
knew of the pla his way around
we were allowed to take a camera in
there we put those stories together
put them on the air in november and man
it just went
through the roof um every night of these
nine
this nine part series people got uh the
audience got bigger phones ringing off
the hook
people calling giving us information
suddenly it's on something called
paranet which was uh sort of a precursor
to the internet
and it was huge and and um it changed my
life for sure i had no idea
that there were so many people out there
interested in the topic
and i was hooked and i really got hooked
on lazar not only because his story
personally you know i was interested in
him we became friends i saw what
happened to him
after that live interview and in the
seven and a half months
before we went and i revealed his
identity
people were really messing with him i
mean there were you cannot convey what
it was like how weird it was then
breaking into his house leaving the
windows open messing with things in his
in his home
breaking into his car leaving the doors
and windows down
just messing with his head and you think
that was the government that was doing
that yeah i do
i think so and then so i had put out a
call to people hey
i want other people to come forward this
is before his identity was revealed we
should explain yes
i am actively seeking information from
the public
if you ever worked at area 51 or s4 you
know anything about this
you're at nellis air force base reach
out to me so i started getting calls
and six people right in a row who had
talked to me on the phone
and offered to give me information were
visited right after the call
one of them was a guy who did tax
returns for people at nellis air force
base and he had got to know these guys
really well
and got information about crashes there
was a guy who was a golf pro
at nellis who had gone on out road road
trips with
officers and told him about this weird
stuff out at area 51 that seemed to be
from somewhere else
uh he gets visited and told to shut up
there was a lady who worked
in the court system a cop told me about
her
and i talked to her on the phone and she
had worked at the court system but
before
she had worked for a company called
holmes and narbor which is a defense
contractor
and she said she sat in as a
stenographer in these meetings
and heard these conversations between
the government contractors
and air force officials about crashed
saucers
and they would after the meeting they
took take the tape
out of the typewriter and and destroy it
and take all the notes and
she agreed to tell me the story it was
just a tiny piece of the story the next
day she's visited by these two guys
in suit they tell her look
you are still subject to your security
clearance i hope you know that and then
they said
we know you travel to la to see your
daughter
and we know she comes here it's a big
desert out there it'd be terrible if
something happened to either one of you
this lady is scared shitless she didn't
make that stuff up
so six people who had offered to give me
information on the phone one right after
another get visited
and it made me mad it also made me mad
that
dealing with you know trying to fill in
pieces of bob lazar's life now i know
there's some gaping holes i know it
better than anybody i've had to deal
with it for 31 years
but i always thought if if he worked at
los alamos in classified projects
in a scientific or technical capacity
then it would make sense that he could
get hired into a program like s4
as somebody who thinks outside the box
despite
personal shortcomings or whatever they
might bring somebody like him in
to help him crack a problem that they
hadn't been able to resolve themselves
so
i focused on los alamos i knew he had
been there i talked to people who
remembered him from being there
but the lab kept telling me no no record
of him he's never here
and then i showed him well look i've got
the los alamos newspaper
it's a small town paper there it is on
the front page a front page story
bob lazar physicist maison facility los
alamos lab
it's a story about his jet car no still
have no records of him and and then i
found his name in the phone book
from the arrow when he was there he's in
the lab phone book he had been hired by
a company called kirk meyer which is a
company that's a a headhunter that fills
positions at los
alamos and places like that so great
i'll reach out to kirk meyer they said
yeah we hired him
yeah we've got records can i get it can
i get his employment records
that would show where he went to school
whatever information you guys had
yes a couple weeks go by nothing
um a couple more weeks go by i call them
again i start writing them i've got a
stack of letters that thick it went on
for
two and a half years and finally by the
end of it they said he was never here we
don't have any records
that that pissed me off it made me mad
and i think that that is really what got
me hooked in the story
um is that i was being jacked around by
government and
national facilities like that we should
explain the los alamos thing because the
los alamos thing
coincided with him doing work at mit
right is that
that correct that's how he's explained
it explained it yeah and the way he
explained it to me
i don't think i'm at liberty to say what
the project was because the project
the way he was describing it is uh
essentially internationally illegal like
what they were working on
and that's one of the reasons why he was
saying
he explained what the project was it
sounded very feasible also very evil
and then it was it was basically a
weapon
and then he said that this is the reason
why there was no
actual record of him studying at mit
it wasn't important that he got a degree
it was important that he understand
that the technical specifications of
what they were attempting to accomplish
that's my understanding as well and you
know it's always been the most
problematic part of his background and
it's where
a lot of people in the bob lazar story
that's where they stop
but the thing is when you listen to him
talk
and when he describes thing it's very
clear he's educated
oh he's a brilliant guy but here's i had
always told him and i've
you know bob you're my friend i want to
have a conversation with you about these
claimed degrees because i didn't believe
that he'd ever sat down
you know in those days you go to a
college like mit or caltech
and get a degree you've got to take
classes in something other than science
you'd have to
i could not imagine bob lazar taking an
english lit class
to save his life but he is a brilliant
guy he i'll give you an example
in april covet thing is is raging my
wife and i are
staying at home we're getting packages
delivered for food and things of that
sort i'm a little worried
they didn't know about contact whether
you can get it off of cardboard boxes or
whatever
and i mentioned to bob in a phone
conversation i'm thinking about buying
one of these uv
screener systems he goes wait a second
don't buy one i think i've got the parts
that i can make you one in my garage
and a week later it arrives this thing
he's got it in his garage handmade this
big scanner with these uv things that
that works he just whipped it up in his
garage i'll remind you
you got the the scanner i got a laser
gun
you got a laser gun i did man it is
super powerful so it's like a handheld
toy that he retrofitted with a
superpower so i'm like lighting [ __ ] on
fire in my house
so it looks like a handheld toy but it's
actually a real
laser it's a toy with full noise but he
put a diode in there and it's
super powerful like it can light [ __ ] on
fire my wife hates that [ __ ] so i got
the laser gun
you also got the flamethrower though
lazar made a flamethrower this is before
your buddy elon
made flames yeah well it's a mask
massive yeah he's obviously a very
intelligent man
um when you listen to him talk there's
no bullshitting going on when he talks
about very
when he talks about undeniable concrete
things when it comes to science when it
comes to
elements when it comes to propulsion
systems he clearly knows what he's
talking about
and the the really confusing thing
for people that are detractors is he
really hasn't changed his story
in 31 years it really is the same story
and that's really hard to do
even if you tell a true story 31 years
later you get it screwed up a little bit
it's hard like when you're calling on 30
like if i
had to remember things from 31 years ago
that's like
i'm one year in a stand-up comedy 31
years ago i don't remember it
i i barely i'm gonna tell you like oh
yeah it was a sunday night and then my
friend greg go actually was wednesday
[ __ ] yeah you're right it was wednesday
who is the host you know we'll have
it i don't know it's a blurry slideshow
but
bob has been remarkably consistent the
only thing that he's vacillated on
we varied a little bit is the whether or
not he saw
an alien or whether or not he saw
someone who was
looking at something that was the size
of an alien
like a small figure like whether or not
they were trying to determine how large
a creature would have to be to use one
of those small crafts because
the crafts were very small in terms of
like uh
for for a human being they were it was
more like something that was built for a
child
and he walked by a window and looked
inside and in
some of the earlier discussions of it he
believed that he might have seen an
alien
but he was really clear that he only saw
it for literally a second as he was
walking by
saw something and again you know how the
brain works in memory you could
you can really plant false memories
everybody wants to pretend their memory
is so good
memories are terrible well bob admitted
from the beginning
remember with the first interview we did
i think it was june of 89 so it was a
little after we did that live interview
but months before we went with his id
and that was really we recorded it in
case something happened to him he was
afraid he was going to be killed
there were a lot of really weird things
going on and and i was worried about it
too i wanted to get it on the record in
case suddenly he disappeared so we
recorded this long interview and
and always he downplays stuff like that
that's an example
yeah i might just i saw something that
was that size
i don't believe it was an alien it was
just a glimpse maybe they're messing
with my head
he also admits that they did mess with
his head
that he had to uh they underwent some
kind of uh hypnosis that they made him
drink this weird green
liquid probably lsd well maybe
um they said it was an allergy test but
yeah i mean but you know
to your point just real quick is uh
after 30 years it's not that he
changed his story he's changed so when i
was interviewing him you know he cracked
the book back open with me
it was like he was saying the science
and technology is what i know i had my
hands on that i can't attest to what i
read in the documents
yeah i saw something for a brief
millisecond through a [ __ ] window
but i don't know what that was so so
people have taken what he said and
exaggerated it bob has always been
skeptical
of the things he didn't have his hands
on and i admire that and he's changed as
a human as a human he's matured
so now he's saying okay let me look at
it rationally i don't know what i saw
through that window right
i appreciate that he's so straight yeah
he's very straight
you know they various scenarios have
popped up over the years about why he
came forward there are people who
believe he just made it up he was trying
to make money or he wanted attention
there are people who believe it's
government disinformation to distract
attention
from something else that was going on
out there or they believe both of them
which you know they would seem to be
mutually exclusive bob would admit that
he had no business being there
that they maybe that there were much
more qualified people to work on those
kind of things
maybe he was a guy who thinks outside
the box who might give a new slant on
trying to figure this stuff out that
they had had for
decades and had not had not uh been able
to duplicate we should explain that a
little bit the los alamos lab story was
him
he put a jet engine on a honda right and
it's
it was a functional jet car that he
built himself
so he was a legitimate propulsion expert
and again like a super science nerd
like where he got his education is
what's weird right i
finally got an interview with the guy
that wrote that article two weeks ago
so the guy uh terry english right
finally after all this time he called me
back three years late you know what i
mean
put him in the movie and i said look
here's the point you said bob lazar was
a
physicist at los alamos so how did you
base that you're writing a paper and he
goes yeah and it got picked up by ap
news
he goes if i had misrepresented that he
was a physicist at los alamos
i would have been blackballed by
everybody at los alamos they take that
very seriously
he was a physicist i reported it ap news
picked it up they repeated it
not word one from anybody saying he
wasn't a physicist at los alamos
it's little things like that that you
know nothing bob has ever said
have i found out yeah this is a real hot
rod
and he did the story because the car was
badass when he fired it up
when he has a history of this he also
made a hydrogen-powered corvette
later on uh yeah he's uh he's a wizard
he's a very smart guy
you know he he will admit to you that
maybe he was picked for the job
they figured all right in case he blabs
we can discredit this guy like that when
we're done with him
there's things in his background he
likes it to blow things up he likes
explosives he
had a pirate flag on his on his house at
the time that i first met him
uh he he liked machine guns he you know
he had an illegal fireworks show that
would
go out in the desert every year that
became a a world-class event
he uh got into some legal trouble after
he'd worked out there so there's a lot
of things in his life they could use to
discredit him but
the people who still maintain that bob
was a disinformation plot
it was meant to distract attention out
from something else going on out there
whoever came up with that idea should be
fired because as a result of bob
coming forward with that story area 51
is now known all over the world
and i'm sorry but the bob lazar version
of of that sto the tale
is the one that prevailed it's known
everywhere it's been in movies and books
and tv shows it
it's launched a thousand different uh
you know project
products like the the hat yeah las vegas
51s our
aaa baseball team became the 51s because
the lazar story
the e.t highway is created and
christened by our governor um
you know that that story that version
that he told is now known all over the
world
whether detractors like it or not and if
somebody was trying to distract the
tension
away from something going on at area 51
it failed miserably
because tens of thousands of people made
the trek out there even today 31 years
later
every single day there's somebody with
binoculars or a scope or something
looking for whatever is flying around
out there every major news organization
in the world
after giving me nothing but grief has
made a beating a path to area 51's door
all of them they have all done it and
bob's story about reverse engineering
craft from somewhere else is now part of
a much larger
and current uh series of events that we
can get into
yeah and that story that he told when he
was on the podcast here
got phenomenal response there were so
many people that i talked to that were
my friends who were skeptical about that
[ __ ]
they they call me up and go hey man i'm
i'm starting to believe this is real
and i'm like you should watch the
documentary and then you should watch
the commander fravor
interview where he talks about the tick
tock uh the tic tac ufo
that they encountered off of san diego
because you're talking about a
rock-solid military man with no
shenanigans in his background
who is telling a story about a craft
that they cannot explain
doing things that defy physics in our
understanding of propulsion systems
and quite a few people from that
interview have completely changed their
tune friends of mine who thought it was
total horseshit have done a 180 and
they're like [ __ ] is this real
then the new york times story came out
of course and the new york times is
showing
all these images of these ufos and these
these things that they can't explain
that all exhibit very similar
propulsion methods or at least
speeds that they can't explain they move
the same way
and there's legitimate people legitimate
scientists now
that are starting to take this into
consideration and say okay
if this is from earth then there's got
to be some sort of a program
that has technology that's far beyond
anything we knew was possible
how did they do that is it because
there's some super geniuses that the
government gets a hold of right when
they're in college and they immediately
ship them off to the desert and have
them create this stuff
or are we in fact encountering something
like us from the future or something
from another place
that has had a completely different path
to technology
but it's not outside the realm of
possibility we're here
we're here sending videos through our
phones to each other
you know we're talking to people that
you know it's being relayed but
through the sky we're watching films
that are instantly downloaded wirelessly
from these servers i mean with the just
the technology that we have right now
is completely alien to anybody who was
around in roswell in 1947
from 1947 to 2020 in terms of the
universe is
not even a half of a blink of an eye and
then boom things have changed so
radically it's not
it's not crazy to think that something
from
somewhere is far ahead of us yes so
that's one of the big things
getting commander fravor in that room
with bob was so cool because people
bob talks to whoever he's talking with
he helps you understand what he's saying
he can go into high specified detail on
stuff but typically he's just talking to
whoever's there
when when i got him in front of
commander fraver all of us and matt we
were all in the room
it was amazing because commander fraber
saw it too he saw something like bob saw
it
and the way that the craft the tic tac
moved it it cannot
be something that we have because it was
clearly
gravitationally propelled this is
something they talk about commander
framers saw it
bouncing like a ping-pong ball on the
inside of a glass
the the inertia being able to go and the
coolest thing bob said was
well command favored dave it could have
been a
a subject to a time distortion so you're
seeing it one way and they started
talking about gravity amplification
it was just so cool to see them talk
without an audience
what the [ __ ] did commander fraber see
and bob was it's cool that when he
can be calm and chill like that and just
talk to another human
and what's crazy is what commander
fravor is describing
is what bob was describing the
propulsion systems of 1989
they were working on straight up it's
the exact same thing even the way it
turns sideways
to move to move off well that's exactly
how he was describing it
yeah that's which is crazy you know we
have this video and everybody says
oh it's this it's that it's another
plane an fa18 dude
i've talked with a dude at boeing now
who he
serviced these pods that it was caught
on the gimbal
that thing is self-rotating it is a
saucer-shaped thing that is rotating
mechanically against the wind
we they all know that this is has to be
a gravity-propelled program we we
understand the science that it takes to
do it
we can't replicate jeremy pull that so i
i always do that it's okay
we have it right up to your face we
can't replicate it right with our
material sciences
our best information at this time we
can't replicate this technology but we
do understand how it works
fundamentally fundamentally we just
don't have the power to actually make it
the material science even just the
actual physical material science the
materials it's made out of and that's
what's been in the news now
metamaterials that there
are materials from craft that we have
george will talk about that but lazar is
parallel with what we're seeing today
yeah and what's also really
bonkers is in 89 he was talking about
element 115.
he wasn't even scientifically proven to
exist until 2013.
so in 1989 he was talking about this is
science fiction he's making things up
in 2013 they actually were able to
create
for a brief moment an element 115 which
is this insanely dense element that they
believe
is perhaps the propulsion system for
this craft
it was always theorized of course
element 115 but
fabricating it was an achievement but
yeah if you're talking about being a
winner
every time history writes itself right
bob is
it's insane he's batting 100 he knew
there was a place called s4 there had
been no
no articles about that no mention i
looked for it you know i called nellis
air force base and asked him do you have
a
place called s4 anywhere on the range
yeah
in fact we have more than one so can you
tell me where they are no
can you tell me what goes on there no
well there was a facility at papoose
i i think it was built in the into the
side of the mountain and you can see the
dirt road on the old satellite photos
why were people going down there and
then of course the video he goes out
there with his friends
when he thinks he's going to be killed
or or he's going to disappear and he and
three weeks in a row you've talked about
on this program
and they videotaped this and all the
witnesses who were there have
verified it and it was not over area 51
it was over papua's which
officially has no no facility nothing
has ever been there
bob knew a lot of stuff that he couldn't
have known otherwise and it's
it's been proven and he didn't know
stuff that was disproven
he didn't come out he didn't make up a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] that you go
like like the william cooper book right
like
there's a lot of people that have
speculated what that was all about
whether william cooper was just
schizophrenic
whether he was writing some truths mixed
in with crazy things
so you could discount the truth i mean
that is that is a real strategy that the
government will employ
if they know that information is going
to get leaked out
and they want to somehow another
discredit it they'll connect it to
really
loony stuff that is absolutely not true
and you'll say
where did you get that information oh i
got it from behold the pale horse
oh christ did you read all the stuff in
that book right i mean so
there's there's that thought but there's
none of that with bob with bob
everything that he talked it's it's so
eerie every time you turn over a stone i
think i'm going to find
at first that's how george and i met i
thought i was going to see these guys
cooked it up that was my first entry
point in 2012
i thought they cooked it up every stone
you turn over to be clear what george
just said
bob always said there's a place called
site four that was never mentioned
anywhere at papoose
he verified it in 1989 with head of
public relations
who was a homie of his at area 51. we
then call
30 years later and they give us the
funniest [ __ ] answer
trying to not talk about site force so
he confirmed it
every time you turn over a stone man
every time
bob's proven right and it's it's
annoying what was the
experiment that he did with element 115
that you guys videotaped it was that
available
online could someone watch that no
so it was called a cloud chamber test so
he he had this stuff
i know people don't believe that it
exists and he never had any of it
they're welcome to believe it but he had
he had a piece of it he didn't steal a
piece
the only time i ever saw it was in his
lead shield round
disc and he had it uh for a while it was
in another
because it's radio radioactive i think
it's stable i don't think it's
radioactive that's how it was shipped to
him
so it's in a disk protect it from
bombardment because it will become
unstable very quickly that's how
he says they used it in the craft so
yeah he had it in a puck and and fi and
a hockey puck looking um yeah like a
metal sandwich and it's lead
yeah yeah yeah and i showed it and i had
it in the background in one of our
stories just out of an inside joke it's
sitting in there but bob used to keep it
in front of a particle accelerator
that he had built at his home you know
every every non-scientist
every non-scientist builds a particle
accelerator in their home and he had it
there
when he thought he was going to be
killed he it was sort of a defense
mechanism for him he had it right in
front all he had to do is flip a switch
and he he thought it could explode um i
think he meant to scare people from
coming
in trying to trying to take him out but
this cloud chamber test was the only
time
i think he ever took it out of this
thing and i got there right as that as
the experiment ended where they had
this little chamber and it bent light
now they were they showed me the video i
don't pretend to be a scientist
i i don't try to be an expert on things
i really don't know
but it looked to me like light was
bending in this experiment which
it shouldn't be able to do it's a like a
laser that bent i've seen
some of this jeremy i was able to find
man this was a search so george
from day one when you have it right now
on video
uh on me it's in my movie right yeah
okay so
but basically what happened is it's so
annoying i'm like
you guys have footage of this because
bob never filmed this to put out to the
public it was to show his friends like
taking them to the test site show them
the saucers
it was so his friends didn't think he
was [ __ ] crazy so
they film it and lo and behold they give
it to george
it's in a brown case it's somewhere in
his archives i've sorted through his
whole
damn house man i can't find this tape so
then i asked bob
is there anywhere this could be anywhere
else this is important footage bob
and i find it sandwiched between two
golden girls episodes on some tape he
kind of recorded over so i got out to
the public what 17 or
30 seconds of this cool down phase of
the test is that online anywhere
it's it's in my film i can put it on
right but is it online is it no no no no
i got it i found it in these old tapes
they they created but you know how to
people take little things from movies
and sometimes oh yeah maybe maybe
somebody
it but i'll i'll post it man i'll put it
it's cool it's cool it doesn't but bob
says he's so unimpressed with everything
he's like jeremy that doesn't show the
cool part of the test it's just the cool
down period
and i'm like well it shows that you
filmed this with your friends back then
and that
at least you believed you had 115. so
what i have
in the film it's not definitive proof
but it shows that
they weren't lying that they filmed it
george was there
bob would just assume that that goes
away that people not talk about it yeah
that's it that's it
jimmy's the best jamie so what's
happening here
explain this looks like he's growing a
plant or some [ __ ] right so this is why
bob was so unimpressed with what i found
sandwiched in his personal home videos
that's the disc that's the top of the
disc
look across yeah so he was trying to
show his friends like today if you had a
laser pointer so here's the here's the
cloud you can look at it over there
jeremy if you don't want to turn around
oh got it
um so so if bob had a laser pointer back
then with the principles of the 115
which he did get out and he doesn't
where's the 115 in this image inside of
the this the clam shell inside of the
puck
so that's that surface we're looking at
the surface of this clamp at the top of
this thing
yeah and so he'd he'd have it in there
now the whole sensitivity for him
is his real world implications if he's
telling the truth to us about it
i don't understand what i just saw
though i didn't see anything you didn't
see it bendy we don't really play that
again it's the only piece of the
tape that still exists but it's not the
key part of that all it shows
joe is that they filmed a home
experiment back then
he demonstrated for his friends how
light was bent
by the material itself i understand that
but i'm not seeing that you're not
you're not seeing so this is the only
piece of the tape that still exists but
it's not this the central piece
was this in the film yeah it was briefly
i didn't highlight it because it was
like
i'm not seeing anything in this this is
what's confusing to me this seems like
nothing
like nothing's going on at all right
that that's the point is that he has a
long version
george blame him yeah it's my fault but
i understand but why is this in the film
then if nothing's happening it was a
splash
over him when he was talking about 115
he doesn't like how
talking about how he got it out but it
was like a easter egg jeremy wanted to
demonstrate that that had been the
recording did exist at one point but
that's the only piece that's left of it
i'm the guy who got the tape
so you got a full table i got this one
where it is i have no idea is it in your
house somewhere
i doubt it i mean i've looked he's
looked i've looked where
could it be dude you should you should
see his house
yeah joe i looked for years man i went
through made him take and digitize
all these tapes i took hundreds of tapes
and digitized them looking for this
little
two minutes that seems like a big deal
though yeah it's a really big deal
i mean i've i've got thousands of tapes
um
from that era and i have saved them all
and i've moved them around
and then i'd use them in different
productions i can't find it i know that
that is very unsatisfactory for people
and that i've been accused of
making it up it's actually very
appropriate considering
the history of this stuff yes it's kind
of funny frustrating as [ __ ] man
of course but but kind of funny the the
aftermath of bob coming forward of
course it it messed with his life
uh in a big way and you know he was not
all that much of a he was sort of a semi
recluse anyway but the stuff that goes
on here even 31 years later you know
what it's like these
uh fanboys he's got people that got the
bob lazar disease really bad
and they still deal with them they spend
their days now all these years later
focusing on bob they're two weeks ago
somebody put something on twitter
it was an interview some these guys had
gone to new mexico to find people that
had worked with lazar a long time ago
and then tried to dig up dirt hey you
remember working with bob or you knew
him back then yeah
did he have uh teenagers working for him
at his photo shop
yeah you ever seen anything weird with
him and little girls
no the guy says and then the interviewer
says well we heard that he tried to
solicit a 14 year old girl to work at a
at a brothel
and then they put this the guy says i
don't think about that
they put this on twitter with the
headline bob lazar solicited 14 year old
girl
to go into prostitution so who who's
doing this just some
discussions online trolls people who've
got it bad um
and there's so many of them that every
day they post something about bob lazar
it's really
yeah every day dude well i think
ufos attract a certain percentage of
schizophrenics
totally but this is like so
horrible the way that his story i mean
they just
i've never seen it like this i've never
i get it i
because i did a film on bob i get death
threats because of bob
that's how that's his life every day you
know i remember
i had a military guy who i had asked uh
years ago about disinformation you know
do you guys have to see
disinformation out there to discredit
the ufo story he said we don't have to
plan anything ufo people do it all to
themselves i mean they're nuts
yeah i had a i got a phd in
ufology in essence by working on that
story and then subsequent stories
because the public had reacted in such a
way
all right i'm going to stick with it but
that what you run into in the topic
it's no wonder that you've gone back and
forth on it so have i yeah
questioning whether is this a good use
of my time because there are so many of
them that are absolutely nuts
and and um psychopaths and they make
stuff up and
and they also make a living doing it
like jamie and i were watching ancient
aliens the other day and we were
laughing
we're like like what are the
qualifications of being a ufo researcher
like you don't have to have a degree you
just you have to be a [ __ ] artist
who's willing to get on the history
channel and talk about ufos like
literally you just have to know a few
facts that you could spit out and some
guys were clearly reading off of a
script
i'm like this has got to be the lowest
bar
for like in terms of like what does your
son do oh
he's a scientific expert on the history
channel amazing
you know but what is he really he's a
[ __ ] ufo researcher well what does
that mean
it just means he's a guy who's into ufos
who can string words together
in a in an appropriate sentence that
seems like he knows what he's talking
about so they put him on tv
and when i did that sci-fi show joe
rogan questions everything
i lost all my faith in ufo research yeah
yeah and i brought it back because of
your
your documentaries what brother and dave
foley because you're talking to dave
[ __ ] love dave i love dave yeah
and but he's so into it man i'm like
really he's like you got to look into
this you got to look into that you know
he's telling
all these things i'm like all right one
more time here we go and then when i
watched your documentary i was like holy
[ __ ]
and it really rekindled my thoughts
about bob lazar because i remember being
really interested in it in the 90s
the topic itself discourages serious
inquiry by journalists by scientists
because you have to wade through so much
crap you know 90
95 of it is total crap or it is honest
misidentifications of prosaic objects
but that five percent
it's really interesting and it's why the
government is now you know
looking into it once again yeah it is
really weird to see the government
looking into it openly that's what's
strange
like the fact that they're like the
younger version of me
would be like bracing myself for contact
like it's coming if they're talking to
us about it now
because my thought was always like they
probably if
ufos are real and aliens exist they have
it in contact they probably don't think
we can handle it
so they probably want to keep us as calm
as possible
and just dismiss everything and go back
to work go back to sleep
do what you got to do don't pay
attention to this this is all nonsense
and that's what most people do
but when the government is actually
openly discussing the fact that they
not only have been studying this but
they have some video footage of some
things
they cannot explain and they're saying
this
just out in public in legitimate
recognized publications newspapers
television shows it's
it's weird to see very weird for me now
it's
you know 33 years that i've been chasing
this and i become
and i don't want to talk about me but i
mean i become the ufo reporter whether i
like it or not
i'm not the ufo reporter i'm a reporter
who is interested in that
the ufo stories i've done and all that
time it's been a lot but
as a percentage of all the reports that
i do it's small
right i'm a news guy i chase bad guys
mostly for the i-team but
those those ufo stories have gone all
over the world
the ufo field is so polluted with um
with liars and exaggerators and fast
buck artists and
and people who appropriate this story
for their own political agendas
um to make money to get attention uh it
it takes
90 percent of your energy just to wade
through the crap and
and get to the hard facts and there
aren't that many of them
and to figure out who's telling the
truth who's reliable who's honestly
trying to pursue
the story and get to the truth um it's
it's a
it's a task that is difficult and i i
don't blame other journalists for not
giving it a fair shake because it's not
something you could do in a week
i remember saying to myself is how cocky
i was in the beginning is
you know i'm reading these ufo books and
boy this field is a mess
but there is some good information in
here give me six months and i'll have
this figured out well
there's 33 years later i know less than
i did now i know i have a lot more facts
in my head
but all the big questions we don't have
answers to them i don't think anybody
does
who they are where they're from why
they're here what they're interested is
in us
what the long-term agenda is we don't
know that and i don't think anybody does
i've gone pretty far high up the food
chain as a career
journalist what what did it feel like to
you
when you started seeing the government
actually coming out and saying
we are trying to investigate these
reports we know that there is something
to them these are real claims
by you know real pilots real scientists
have
have reviewed these things and they find
them troubling
it it's a it's a mix uh the most
immediate reaction is astonishment
because of all the years i'm chasing
this everywhere you go you run into
brick walls when dealing with the
government
that's really what got my attention and
where i wanted to focus
because i can't go out and wait for ufos
to show up although i've done that
but i wanted to follow the paper trail
the government has this whole
big long history of documents that they
exchanged reports memos
incident reports about ufos
uh before the freedom of information act
became the law of the land
and they're very candid with each other
they're not that way anymore they hide
stuff
uh but back in those days they were
candid that this is from somewhere else
this is real it's not fictitious
we we need to look into this we got to
make sure it's not russians or chinese
and we have to figure out who's got this
technology because we don't it's not
ours
and then of course when freedom of
information act became the law of the
land
all these agencies that had lied about
it nope we don't have any ufo
reports have to cough up thousands and
thousands of pages
they have absolutely stonewalled this
and lied to the public
for a long time so to finally see them
admit
yes we're taking it seriously which i
have known all along of course they have
to study this
unknown craft float over our nuclear
missile bases
disarm the missiles we have fighter jets
go after them
they leave them in the dust they can fly
circles around our best technology they
mess with
nuclear power plants nuclear weapons
nuclear
facilities like los alamos it is a
national security issue
and they have been paying attention to
it they just haven't been telling us so
for
the new york times to come out in
december 2017 and say
yeah there was a program and yeah
they've been looking at ufos oh by the
way it's all done now
well it's still a mixture of lies
and and some glimpses of truth but i
never thought i would see this in my
lifetime i never thought i'd see this
much progress
the last two and a half years has been
the most astonishing time
in the history of this subject and i'll
tell you joe there is stuff bubbling
right under the surface now
that is going to uh rock our world i
think in the next year or so
did you see trump on tv being
interviewed by his son yeah it was kind
of hilarious yeah
there's very interesting things very
very interesting we're going to
open roswell we're going to open roswell
i think commentary 51.
yeah well he's barely paying attention i
think he has been briefed
yeah i think he has been briefed more
than once you know i think because he
watches tucker carlson
and tucker's got ufo people on there
once a month does he
yeah he's been he's had for the last
year he's had ufo people once a month or
so lou elizondo and
chris mellon and people like that and uh
i thought
that would if anything that would get
trump's attention because you know
that's what he pays attention to right
that's that's hilarious these stories
about ufos
over nuclear bases and and weapons
facilities and things along those lines
has that been substantiated
oh yeah yeah so this happened tell me
the stories 1975 they called it the
northern tier case so we have a string
of
bases up by the canadian border all the
way across the u.s from maine to montana
nuclear missile facilities they were
ready to go in the darkest days of the
cold war
those those missiles icbms are ready to
go aimed at moscow and other places
and in 1975 74 and 75
one after another these bases were
visited they thought they were mystery
helicopters or something lights in the
sky right over the missiles
in a couple of cases they they disabled
the missiles if we had gone to war
we wouldn't have had those missiles
being able to fire there are some
indications that the launch control
codes were interfered with
and then we scrambled jets the military
personnel had reported this up
and the things go away we can't catch
them whatever
they were it clearly is a threat to
national security can i stop you for a
second
is there an official record of these
encounters yes
and those documents you can find them
washington post broke the story
in the 70s they had obtained some of
these documents
after freedom of information act came
forward and then the
the most recent study bass asap that we
could talk about
they also really focused on the northern
tier cases and they looked up some of
those guys they found
uh some of the nuclear missile officers
and security personnel
and interviewed him and they told the
story all over again there was a guy
named robert hastings
ufo's and nukes he has been his
specialty for the last 30 years
he wrote a book made a film it's
chilling
part of what has happened is it not only
happened to us the u.s
but in russia so once i got ufo fever
and became a ufo reporter
i traveled all over the world and one of
the places i went twice was russia
after the fall of the soviet union it
occurred to me that maybe
we might be able to learn more from the
russians about what our government knows
about ufos than our government will ever
tell us
and i met a russian physicist who was
here in uh
in the u.s to lecture on disarmament
issues
at national labs he was getting ready to
go back to russia he had been the
national security adviser to boris
yeltsin
he was a national security adviser to
the russian parliament he had taught
russian cosmonauts how to spot american
nuclear submarines from space
he was connected so i had a beer with
him at the suggestion of a u.s
congressman
and i said hey nikolai you ever hear any
of your guys
in russia at high levels talk about ufos
now
can't can't really think that i that
doesn't ring a bell we have another beer
and he says you know
i do have a guy at the kgb who told me
that they had looked into it for a while
and i thought well uh they had just the
kgb had just released its oswald files
i thought maybe this is a golden
opportunity to find out what they know
because they are a superpower they have
nuclear weapons they would have seen the
same things we've been seeing so i went
to russia we sent nikolai over to back
to moscow
gave him a stipend and his instructions
were
find people who were in a position to
know high up in the military
or the polit of the government who had
never talked about this before
and it took about eight months for him
to report back and get all these people
lined up and then i went to russia
and met him and interviewed him and
these were former military guys there
was a guy named colonel borosokolov who
was a gold mine of information he told
us about
a previously unknown study probably the
biggest
ufo study in the history of the world
for 10 years from 78 to 88
the russian military empire every
military unit in russia
in their whole military global if they
saw any ball of light
anomalous aircraft ufo anything weird
like that
they had to report it to the kgb and all
that information went to one desk
at the ministry of defense colonel
sokolop was that desk and they had
thousands of reports
that had never been made public before
he told me about
45 different incidents where russian
warplanes had chased ufos couldn't catch
them
three of the instances these ufos shot
him down two of those pilots died
and after that he said the order went
out look if you see these things don't
mess with them
he said their study was for a very
practical reason these craft could do
things that the russians could not
and they wanted to get an advantage over
the americans in terms of stealth
technology so they wanted to do
what people in reverse engineering
programs are doing figure out how the
ufos work
so they could have an advantage over us
i had to smuggle some of these documents
back
if i had been caught with this stuff
because some of it was classified
if i'd been caught i'd still be in a
gulag somewhere but i got it
back i shared it with some people it
eventually found its way into the u.s
government's hands
and it it tells us basically a lot of
what we now know about our own
government
that they have always taken this
seriously and one of the incidents
i'm sorry i made the long way around on
that story was an icbm base
in the ukraine colonel sokolov says that
a
giant ufo appeared over this base these
are missiles that are trained to go to
new york and los angeles they're very
serious stuff there it's a very secure
facility
giant ufo appears over this base it
splits into pieces
and then it melds back apart and and it
performs this dazzling display for a
couple of hours that base is on high
alert
and all of a sudden the nuclear control
facilities
lights up like a christmas tree and
whenever this thing was it
entered the launch control codes
the missiles were enabled they start
firing up they're ready to go
and then poof ufo goes away the whole
thing shuts down
it goes back to normal colonel sokolov
said his team he and his team
sent there to investigate it they took
those machines apart
could not figure out what it had done
and he told me on camera
we think that they were sending us a
message that these are your most
powerful weapons
but we're not impressed same kind of
thing happened here
we don't like to admit it but there's a
pretty strong paper trail that it really
did happen
now what is a bigger national security
issue than that or like the tic tac
you've got a nuclear powered uh carrier
there
and other warships around it and you've
got these strange
radar sightings for a couple of weeks
right off the coast of the u.s
this is an intruder and even though
these aliens whatever they are
are not firing beams and wiping out our
our cities
you have to consider it a threat that's
the job of our defense department
they don't know what it is but they know
it shouldn't be there and it's not ours
um and i think that's what the program
is going on right now
it's a legitimate national security
issue it deserves to be investigated
in spite of the larger social
implications that we're not alone
the the tick tock craft or tic tac
craft god damn
the tic tac craft um that was spotted
off san diego
it performed something spectacular in
terms of its ability to go from the
surface
of the of the water to sixty thousand
feet
in how long so uh less less
less than a second but there's actually
more to it there there was a craft
remember i was talking with commander
favor before this was public
yeah there was a craft under the water
too the tic tac would drop from sixty
thousand feet is what they're saying
sixty to eighty but that's the scan
volume of the spy one radar
so everybody i've talked to said they
were coming from above they were coming
from outer space
dropping down within a second
and stopping on a dime and then making
the movements commander fravor saw
like inside of a glass then he said to
me in our first
talk ever i'll never forget this because
i'm talking to a fighter pilot and i got
a talk fighter pilot and i'm i don't you
know
and he says to me it noticed me i go
what do you mean it noticed you he says
as i was descending rapidly to engage it
it turned its nose and began to
intelligently
mirror my movements came right up by me
and he says faster than you can see a
like you can't even see a bullet leave a
gun
no it's just bam shot off he goes we
don't have anything like that i wish
we did we don't whatever propels that is
not a reactionary propulsion system
meaning it's not pushing something off
the back to get it to go forward like
everything is fire and explosion it's a
field proposal yeah like anything else
we know you've got to have something
going back to go forward rockets we're
still using the same ones from back in
the day
this thing instantaneously without
effects of inertia
can move now and that distortion that's
exactly how bob described these things
would work or do work in his opinion
so commander fraber got to see it now
and these incursions by the way
look there's stuff george reports on
there's a lot he doesn't as a filmmaker
myself
people tell me stories all the time
these incursions
it's not a rarity these are happening to
this day i
just heard about one in guam incursions
over
high security air space over
our weapons systems and in guam there
was just
recently an incursion the pantex
facility
with the igloos where we hold our
nuclear weapons and stuff like that
there are incursions over these so to
george's point
the the reason why maybe all this is
secret is not because we can't handle it
people
flip out maybe we just want to make sure
we [ __ ] get this tech first because
it's a game changer
now let's talk about the people that
have tried to debunk this
and why they're off because they've made
some
debunking claims about some of these
videos
and about the technology that was used
to track these things
that's incorrect where they don't they
don't really understand what they're
debunking right so please please explain
that because
that's one of the things that people are
immediately going to go to they're going
to go well mick west has already
debunked it and
i've read the stuff that he says it's
mental gymnastics
to try to explain it the way he's
explaining it without recognition of the
fact that these things were actively
blocking radar
these things were actively blocking
tracking systems these were
physical crafts this is not like a bird
no or so like a lot of the wacky
theories that he has
are like i wonder you know it's real
weird
like that a smart man can make such
really
bizarre conclusions very weird
almost like someone wants him to do
those
sure i mean look it's so exciting that
that we're seeing something and the
government's saying okay these are ufos
we have
not identified them they have propulsion
techniques
that we don't have and we're not we're
just talking about the videos
let's talk about the debunking okay talk
about the debunking and what his claims
are in the debunking okay so one that i
recently like
you know attacked because it was so
ridiculous is he was saying that
the go fast video which is this you know
object that
goes along uh in a straight line one of
the three videos that was released he
said what was
probably a bird that was his first
theory let's pull up the go fast video
yeah i mean i recently went deep
into talking with uh boeing
experts who who work on these flear pods
they're telling me how they work what
they can capture
why explain what a flare pod is a for a
forward-looking infrared so basically on
fighter planes you have a camera so
here's the video
we're pulling it up right sure that it's
mounted
and it's essentially recording in
thermal imagery these things are
this is not instagram these things are
weapons systems
that are highly trained to be able to
accurately represent
uh spatial awareness and to be able to
target
you know enemy combatants that's this is
not an iphone an instagram
these are weapons for us so out of the
three videos
if we just look at this one although i
like the tic tac one with commander
fraber and i like the gimbal one those
are awesome this one gives us very
little information
but the idea that this would be a bird
if you talk to anybody that uses these
pods you don't
you can't pinpoint on a bird you can't
lock a weapon system
on a freaking bird well look how fast
it's going too
well here's what's so interesting is
everybody can debate speed
so this is where it's locked in on it
right so the weapon system is locked in
on this thing and it's tracking it now
right and and they got real excited when
they locked it because it's
they they said boxed a moving target
right they so here's the deal though
out of anything i could say about this
video because there's not a lot of
information in there
what i can say is that object you're
seeing is colder than the surface of the
ocean
now i looked up the surface of the ocean
temperature at that location at that
time because we had the information
it was like 65 degrees what propulsion
system so okay so a bird a bird is about
a hundred and let's say five degrees
like a seagull
sea goals can go maybe 15 miles an hour
i don't know how fast they can go
but there they wouldn't they wouldn't be
colder than the ocean they'd be
hypothermic and
dead it cannot be a bird because this uh
what we're seeing is a colder object
than the surface of the water
that's why you're seeing it white and
how fast is it going that's under debate
there's different um
interpretations yeah so i'm i'll give
you one interpretation about you know
240 miles an hour some people say
and then they can argue well the fastest
bird in a nosedive could go that fast
back up we have an object that is colder
than the surface of the ocean that
immediately gets rid of the bird
theory because a bird would be
hypothermic and drop like a paperweight
into the water
it cannot fly at that so that's the
piece of information i would attack that
debunking with but this video
when you're watching that if it is going
200 miles an hour
that's not outside of what's possible
with
with spacecraft or aircraft or or just
planes
right but it's cold i understand that
that's pretty cool but it is
no it's very interesting but it's not
moving anywhere near as fast as the tic
tac
no no no this is just something because
this is part and george can tell you
this was part of a much
bigger series of events so like the
gimbal craft
itself that's another debunking thing
they said it's a plane
banking away and you're seeing it
through thermal first of all talk with
the pilot
not [ __ ] so this is the gimbal yeah
the gimbal is pulling it up right now
and how fast is this thing supposed to
be going you know the speed from what i
recall wasn't registered
on the um on the radar it's not that
it's going fast if you talk with the
pilots
it was rotating it was spinning like a
top and
for like 11 hours without refueling i
mean the thing was just sitting out
there this was not
a this is an occurrence that happened
over a course of many many weeks
now when it rotates like that the
debunking theory
is that you're seeing a plane bank so as
if
our military doesn't know what another
plane is
other planes look very different when
you see them through thermal
this thing was self-rotating and i just
did an interview and how fast is
this or rather how warm is this thing
supposed to be
is this supposed to actually be hot i i
i am unaware because you're looking at
it through thermal right yeah i'm
unaware of the specifics of that one
when it comes to heat all i know is that
it is self-actuating
it is not something that is a glare or
flare of a heat signature
making it look like it's turning the
actual craft
is self-actuating and what is the that
halo around it
that's just an artifact of the of the
flea thermal
it's not but the the premise that uh the
us government
would tell you all right look we're
going to release these videos
reluctantly lou elizondo is the guy that
got him released and then the us
government
formally released them a couple of
months ago the idea that the u.s
government would release it the pentagon
says
these are unidentified the and you know
if it was a bird or a uh a jet engine
uh the pilots would not have the kind of
reaction that they had that you can hear
on the audio
our government does not tell uh members
of congress the pentagon doesn't go to
the senate intelligence
committee show them those videos and say
um yeah it's
unidentified if it isn't and you know
the reaction of the pilots uh the
the fact that they would were forced to
release it to begin with
suggest that it really is unidentified
why do you think they've addressed it
why do you think that they have
addressed the fact they're studying
these things why not just continue
denying it
i think they were forced to uh and some
props to tom delong
i know you guys had a pretty spirited
conversation when he was here
but he created that organization um
lou elizondo who ran that program came
forward
and brought with him those videos i saw
them two days after
uh louis lozando stepped on a stage with
tom and said i was in charge of the
program
he and chris mellon have been sort of
the engineers
of getting that story into the new york
times
that changed everything as i said the
last two and a half years
um everything has turned on its head the
new york times covers the story the
result is
other media covered as well they've been
ignoring it forever and and
and that allowed people who keep these
secrets that pressure
meant that people in congress started
asking questions
two days after the story came out i
interviewed senator harry reid
who was the one who got the money to
create that program that became atep
and he said his phone had been ringing
off the hook from other members of
congress
who are now suddenly interested i didn't
know there was a program they're telling
him
how do we learn more about this it
started a series of closed door
briefings on capitol hill
that continued to this day the pilots
like dave fravor were hauled before
congress
first in front of the staff of the
senate intelligence and then senate
armed services
and then the elected members these these
senators who get briefed on it and they
were impressed and they wanted more
pilots to come in
so it's been going on for two and a half
years and two weeks ago
no excuse me about a month ago now the
culmination of it senator marco rubio
is now the chairman of the senate
intelligence committee drops this bill
and it's the budget for the intelligence
budget for the next year
and he includes a ufo provision in there
we want congress wants to have a
mechanism set up where we get regular
briefings
from the pentagon on ufos that's an
astonishing
change of events it's because the media
pressure and then congressional interest
it made it um more acceptable for
everybody
to pursue the subject matter it's kind
of out of the shadows and the
pentagon has reacted in fits and starts
so sometimes as they said to the new
york times
that program ended had nothing to do
with ufos
at first they said it did then they said
it didn't they've admitted lou elizondo
worked on the program then they said he
didn't
um they've said that the awsap which is
the other program the mother program
that became atep that that had nothing
to do with the
ufos what it did so they continued to
sort of lie and obfuscate and muddy the
waters
but the fact is that there's too much
momentum from media
and congress and the public to hide this
anymore
you should tell joe about how the the
government program awesome
was created directly because george
wrote this book about a little place
called skinwalker ranch where the
government was studying this property
that happened because of his book some
dia guys well you should tell the story
i visited that place
yeah but you yeah right yeah yes
yeah i i i think you got a i think you
got a little misleading
tell him tell him how the governments
that he had
started you know from your work it's
fascinating so some of it
some of it stems back to lazar so we did
that story in the series in 89
one of the first people to call me after
that was a guy i'd never heard of before
named robert bigelow
a billionaire he calls me up and says i
was really interested in that i've been
interested in ufos for a long time
can i help you meaning can he help fund
me i said i work for a tv station i
don't need any help
but he was not to be deterred he then
reached out to lazar they had a little
he started meeting with him and and
pumping up for information
and that really amplified bigelow's
lifelong interest in it
he created something called nids the
national institute
for discovery science which he he made a
science advisory board
of the best and the brightest in the
both the ufo field and the field of
consciousness
so they're looking at two questions is
there is there life elsewhere in the
universe is it here
and is uh do humans survive after death
and he assembled this board a former cia
guys
two former astronauts men who had walked
on the moon dr edgar mitchell
dr hal put off physicists um
psychologists
a really a brilliant little think tank
to take on these two topics
i was allowed to be a fly on the wall
for some of it not all of it but some
and i told harry reid about it in 1996
and he said can i go and so he showed up
and sat in on the meetings
and he was kind of hooked harry reid was
the first person i told about bob lazar
outside of our newsroom
when i before we aired the stories he
had i'd known him since he first ran for
uh congress in 1982 then he becomes
senate majority leader
so he'd always had an interest in it but
he didn't want it to be known publicly
that does not help your re-election
chances so in
2005 we write the book about skinwalker
ranch
nids that team bought the ranch they
were on the property for seven or eight
years at that point
and had hundreds of different incidents
that they investigated
they approached it like scientists would
they looked for prosaic explanations
they look for
gravity anomalies they like look for
psychoactive plants could there be
hallucinations
caused by magic mushrooms or something
are the witnesses lying they
investigated the background of the
family that had lived there
and they found out that they it could
not be uh explained
all the range of activity there so it
was not only you have an activity we're
talking about well which starts with
ufos because that's what got their
attention
the uinta basin in northeastern utah has
always been a ufo hotspot everybody who
lives there basically
has seen them balls of light orbs
structured craft daylight night time in
1976
a guy named dr frank salisbury wrote a
book about it the utah ufo display and
he took
hundreds of these cases that had been
collected by the locals there was a
local science teacher named junior hicks
who because he had taught generations of
kids
science in that area when they people
would see ufos they'd call up
junior hicks and he went and go and
investigate him and he'd had
hundreds and hundreds of files he gave
them over this guy salisbury who wrote a
book about it and he said
these are real you know they're going on
but junior hicks would disregard
any high strangeness cases that came
along with the ufos
anything weird bigfoot ghosts anything
like that
he thought it was too incredible and he
and he discarded that bigelow
buys the ranch he hears about these
stories going on on this one property
flies in meets with a rancher and by
this time that rancher and his family
had lived on the ranch for 20 months
and they were so scared that he his wife
and his two kids
were all sleeping at night on the floor
in the same room
because it had messed with them so badly
um
their property had had ghost type
activity
poltergeist kind of things trickster
activity
for example the wife goes shopping to
the grocery store
she buys it all this food comes back
puts it on the table
takes out puts it in the shelves leaves
the room comes back in all the food's
back in the bag
she would take a shower in the morning
locks the door puts a towel
and a hairbrush on the cabinet gets out
of the shower door's still locked
hairbrush and towel are gone dad's out
in the field he is
digging a post hole using a post hole
digger happy piece of equipment
he stops for a second wipes his brow
looks back and it's gone
and they find it two weeks later up in a
tree they start hearing voices at night
in in the air speaking of strange
language they start seeing
shapes outside the window at night big
lurking humanoid shapes
hearing heavy footsteps outside then
hearing heavy footsteps inside
then their animals started being
mutilated cows
uh would the the tracks would lead out
into the snow and then
just be gone calves mutilated cut up
with surgical precision
cats uh wiped out cut carved up
dogs that were vaporized hundreds of
these incidents um
they would see holes in the sky like a
great big hole
in the sky and things flying in and out
of it now this rancher
college educated guy grounded uh
strictly
religious guy thinks the government is
trying to run him off his property
so he's out there at night lurking with
a gun trying to catch whatever
government agents are doing this stuff
and it's not government agents it was
something else they start seeing
ufos of all shapes and sizes the first
one they saw was like a
they thought it was a winnebago this
ranch is a beautiful place
and it only has one way in and one way
out they see these two lights that look
like headlights down in the third
homestead
how did this guy get past the house here
and get down there he must be stuck
let's go down and help him out the
lights start coming toward he and his
son
then they go up into the sky up over the
trees and then poof
gone um these different kinds of orbs
the white ones that were intelligently
controlled not fireflies not bugs
uh blue ones that would go they seem to
touch the the fear center in your brain
they'd get near them they looked like a
little bigger than a softball made out
of glass with a swirling blue liquid
scared the hell out of the animals and
then it scared the hell out of the
the people too this literally drove them
to their knees with fear
these red orbs that would stampede the
cattle
they lost so many cattle that they began
to to think that they were going to go
under
they had these four prized bulls i know
i'm jumping around but there's a lot of
stories
they had these four prized bulls 2 000
pounds
each behemoths very expensive animals
because they were raising cement hall
cattle
had them in the in the uh corral and the
husband and wife
they always felt like they're being
watched he says to the wife as they're
driving to town
man if something happens to one of those
bulls we'll go under we'll be done
they come back a half an hour later all
four of the bulls are gone
they jump out they're freaking out where
did they go did somebody steal them are
they rustlers looking around all over
the place
in this corral is a metal trailer where
they used to store
uh tools and there's only one door into
it and it's re
it's locked with this heavy piece of
wire the door is still locked the wire
is still on there the guy
just as a last resort he looks into the
grating on top of
this trailer and there's the four bulls
inside
doors still locked they're all crammed
in there now you could take a forklift
you could have a team of 50 people and
they couldn't get those bulls
in that trailer but there they were he
yells to his wife
hey honey they're in here and when he
says that the bulls wake up
as if out of a a trance kicked the
the door down and all got out the nids
team which had been on the property for
a couple of years at that point
um fly in they had been in las vegas
they fly back in
they look around they check out the
animals the whole corral which is made
out of metal had been magnetized
so whatever technology was used to get
those bulls
from the corral into that trailer left a
magnetic signature
they were there on the property the knit
skies for several years bigelow owned it
for 20 years
but eventually they gave up whatever
this thing was this intelligence
it did not like being stalked and it
played tricks on them
and they never made the stuff public
because what are you going to do write a
paper about this who who's going to
print it
you can't make a a a documentary about
it because they weren't there is there
any evidence
well all this we're saying those cattle
mutilations i guess that's some evidence
but that's the only evidence of cows
and we can mutilate cows what what about
all this other stuff
like for the first 20 months when the
rancher is there they don't have any
evidence because
he's not a paranormal investigator
they're not taking photos or something
they want it to go away so they don't
have any evidence of that
except for what the rancher told them
but then they talked to the larger
community
and the same thing has been happening to
all the neighbors the guy who lives next
door had lost all these cattle as well
seized the craft sometimes these craft
would float around they looked like
uh stealth fighters with christmas
lights around them floating around
silently
again again not really i mean so
bigelow puts up cameras all over the
property
and you had them focused here where some
activity had happened before the thing
moves over here
you you move the prop the camera's in
focus there it goes away
toward the end of the study whatever it
was that was there
ripped the one of these cameras would
rip the shreds if they're up on top of a
telephone pole
30 40 feet in the air and there's wires
that are all secured all the way down
the telephone pole
and they notice that one of their
cameras goes out they figure well
there's another camera on another pole
that should have a view of whatever it
was
that tore this up some kind of animal or
whatever or whatever
it was was invisible and i know it's
very frustrating it certainly was for
them and for me to try to write about it
in that this thing didn't want to be
caught
it wanted to demonstrate it that it was
there but it didn't want to have
evidence
the calf that was mutilated was in i
know it's it's
it's a lot to handle yeah the calf that
was mutilated it was a sunday morning
it's 10 o'clock on a quiet morning it's
daylight
the rancher and his wife are there by
themselves they're tagging newborn
calves tagged their ears
and they tagged this one right by the
ranch house 50 yards from their home
and they go off across the property it's
a clear day it's unobstructed
that their dog is with them and makes a
noise that points them back toward that
first calf that they had uh
tagged and the and the dog indicates
that something's wrong and they see the
mom
cow is dragging its leg and going around
in a semicircle
it's in distress they go running back
over there and this calf had been
completely stripped of flesh
nothing left but a hide and bone and one
of the
femur bones have been ripped out and
thrown on the side
well they call in the nids guys they
bring in trackers there are no tracks
there's no
human tracks no no vehicle tracks no
animal tracks
the thing had been completely stripped
of blood there's not a drop of blood on
the ground
it's gone 75 pounds of meat gone
again over a time period of 30 minutes
um is there a team of commandos that
comes in and does that uh
where's reporters yeah and there's this
is there's evidence of this
yeah photographs yeah video can we see
that
yeah where is it i mean i made a movie
called for the skinwalker it's in there
right is that the only place
yeah it's it's probably it's probably
some other places there's photos and
videos i mean
so that the i'm with you man what's the
speculation about like why
why would they do this and why would
they do the cattle mutilations like what
is
yeah is there any speculation some
so some of it is a demonstration i mean
it seemed to be a demonstration to get
their attention
this trickster element has been reported
in other places around the world
there's no hot spot quite like
skinwalker and i know how weird it it
sounds
there's no spot like that because it's
never there's no spot that's been
studied to that extent
the nids guys were there for well big
loan the property for 20 years
nids was active for seven or eight then
another secret study
funded by the government came in under
an organization called bass
um that was the money that reed got he
got 22 million dollars it went to
bigelow
as a contract and they hired all these
people and fanned out all over the world
to try to find ufo information
but other related phenomena things that
wouldn't seem
normally to be connected to ufos but
which are
a guy from the dia had read the book
and became interested and he asked for
permission to go to the property
this guy's a double phd a brilliant
rocket scientist
who had seen it and thought there were
national security implications the hole
in the sky in particular
with things coming in and out he
wondered if someone was using technology
to make these things film that hole in
the sky
no again that's when the rancher is
there by himself so
he's not he's not a ufo guy he's not
trying to i understand
um but is there any evidence of anything
weird
anything other than mutilated cows
well let's see the the video of the
camera that was torn up by something
invisible they had something that did
so in the video you can see the camera
being torn apart you can't see anything
you can't there's nothing you can't see
anything you can see
before it happens uh it's normal and
afterward
so i think how much time is taking place
between before and after
i can't remember but i mean could that
be hoaxed
yeah if bigelow wanted to but again they
weren't there to
in the beginning at least for nids they
weren't there to
uh to try to prove that aliens are
visiting they're just trying to figure
out why all this weird stuff
is happening in one spot right it mixes
in a lot of
native american lore that got mixed in
the picture but it's been going on in
that you went to basin for
200 years why don't know
our government has studied the medic so
like what is evidence it's so
frustrating to me too when i was
introduced
to the skinwalker thing through george
man i i'm with you
like what's the evidence what's going on
the weight of evidence is when you
talk to people in the area and they all
have these commonalities some people
died of exotic cancers from burns from
above where lights came down and hit
them and that's evidence their face is
completely irradiated and they [ __ ]
died so there's the cow
so you have a scientist like dr colin
kelleher hold on for a second
that's where they found it look at that
yeah just
what in the [ __ ] can that that is so cra
you know
did they scan the area to look for
another spot where it could have been
slaughtered before it was moved to this
area well that's what they concluded is
it had to have been taken somewhere
and slaughtered and then brought back
but who does that a little larger please
can you
just um zoom in on that because that
doesn't look very surgical to me that
looks like wolves
yeah it was there's no just just they
actually did an analysis and it was done
with two types of
metallic tools but look at all the
jagged edges
they said they so they took samples and
they sent them to two pathology labs
didn't tell the guys what they're
looking for you tell us what you can see
and this the pathologist said that two
instruments had been used
one was a heavy machete type instrument
that had been hacked
and then there is a scalpel that had
surgically removed
a lot of the flesh underneath it looks
like something
killed it and then they moved it to that
spot i mean if i had a guess
the way it's eaten though i mean it
looks like it was eaten well there's no
teeth marks there are
metallic marks meaning they
okay so something sharp sliced it so i
think the bigger point is this was
happening on this ranch
with owners prior to owners prior to
owners i got to
talk to a lot of people so here's the
deal the connection of this
so george does this thing he reports on
this for for 20 years
that the government is now studying this
ranch right because of deployment or
because of
all this weird stuff why is the
government spending money
through ossap to study this ranch and
other things and that's where it gets
really [ __ ] interesting
what happens after with our government
programs and that's what you know
this um is before we get to that this
image like the the jagged edges
around the rib cage that's supposedly
sliced that looks like
hacked okay i mean look it could let's
say it's people doing this
you know two farmers to get them out of
there let's say it's some program i mean
although the cattle mutilation thing you
gave me a stack of documents this big
has been studied by the fbi it was
it's happened all over the country no
one has ever been caught
not a single person more than 10 000
cases
with all the same types of cuts i mean
this is not my exercise
i've seen a lot of that it's really
weird there isn't really weird and the
lack of blood is the weirdest part of it
because if see like what makes sense to
me
um is that something killed that
they they butchered it they chopped all
the meat off of it and then they removed
the carcass from that area
and dropped it off there yeah that's
what it looks like if i had a gas
that's what nids thinks there's no way
that it was killed
right there because you're seeing fresh
clean hay
underneath it everywhere there's no
blood which doesn't make any sense at
all
i think the question is is this a
government program is this something or
is this a scare tactic it's been
happening since the 50s like what is a
weird scare tactic
so click on that one below it jamie that
the brown one with the green yeah that
one please
thank you that's that's a weird one too
like there's like a
hole cut out and there's a bunch of
these they found
all over the country and was weirdness
like organs removed
but the weirdest part about it is it's
almost always there's no blood
yeah i just investigated one which i
never thought i would do but i got a
call from a guy in texas you have to see
it physically yeah so right before
lockdown i go out and i'm like this is
so wild i gotta check this out
the guy calls me it's a pretty freshy
one at this point now i'm no
expert but i went and got samples and
took them to labs and this sort of thing
to see if there were tools used
so you got here's my experience you get
pictures of this yeah i filmed
it on your phone i'll show you after i
got on my phone yeah
so i got great foot great [ __ ] photos
weird well listen man
air drop them to me now we'll send them
to jamie and we'll put it up on
on the screen so other people could see
okay so let me
yeah after the show is not going to help
us okay while you're looking i'll tell
them about uh
one of the theories about the cattle
mutilations that dr kelleher dr colin
keller developed was that uh
somebody is tracking the spread of like
mad cow prions
through the food supply and that they've
been doing it under the guise of
ufos since no one would take ufos and
cattle mutilation seriously
they just do it in helicopters and
they're instead of just stealing these
cattle they're tracking how far this
these indestructible prions uh travel
through the food supply because it's in
uh cattle it's in pigs it gets uh
fed into chickens and things of that and
feed it's in deer
it's called chronic wasting disease in
in some circles
it's just weird well quantity it's just
wasting diseases isn't that a that's a
different prion disease
than um mad cow well it's a variation
cruttsville jacob disease i think too so
um
the same kinds of things in different
species
it is indestructible again so you hit a
deer that's got this
and you grind it up and you feed it to
pigs the pigs get it
yeah and then um and then it could be
passed on to other species and it shows
up in different ways
kelleher was exploring the idea well
whether or not it it might be the cause
of alzheimer's or
a version of mad cow in humans do you um
they're all going to you right now this
so this is a recent oh it says
downloading
so oh i'm downloading them and then oh
right right right
are you on the wi-fi no but it's coming
through here we go it's about to go to
you
it says waiting okay got it boom i mean
i guess this does highlight
because this is my very limited amount
of can you send those to jamie too jimmy
yeah are you turning up on air dropped
sorry i should have had to do that
right away it's ready to roll his
airdrop is open
i don't see you bro bro hold on there
there you go young jamie so this is um
this is the stuff that you physically
encountered
okay you physically saw this cow and i'm
looking at these images right now and
we're gonna show them
sure in a second and this is uh you said
texas yeah so where where in texas
oh gosh what was the name of it in the
panhandle
and i'm yeah i'm blanking so here's the
deal
oh yeah that's it so
i made the the movie based on george's
work
of the same title hunt for the
skinwalker right and that
movie was telling this story about how
the united states government was
studying this property of land because
of ufos
and weird stuff that and weird stuff
included things like cattle pull up this
one
there's a lot of weird images man this
uh the the skin
removed around the face right so this is
my
skull this is my first chance to see
this for myself because last time i was
on your show it was the ones in oregon
had just happened
up at that ranch and i thought well okay
if i'm ever gonna do it
now is the time to do it so i go i get
this call
now remind you this is a rancher this is
like this is their livelihood
it's this huge huge area of land that
right there stop right there
they're a very religious community
nobody we go out to the middle of this
land
and in the middle there's this dead cow
no blood no blood and and he had seen it
prior and and the reason he called me
is because in my movie you could see
this special kind of slice like a jagged
slice that is common to these types of
things they think are real mutilations
and he's looking at it he's like that's
exactly like in the movie
now this is a straight shooter he's a
religious guy he had to ask his pastor
if he could even like go on camera with
me
it freaks him out so he sees this now he
sees dead animals all the time
and he saw this cow you said before
accidentally he was out shooting bb guns
with his kid
and he's on this big part of land and he
sees this down
bull and he goes over to it he's looking
at it and it's unlike anything he has
ever seen in all of his years before it
had
surgical cuts there is no doubt somebody
killed cut up this animal with those
classic
like the ear gone uh two types of tools
like a scissor type but by the way i
tried to cut it it is not
easy to cut so they had sharp tools and
then there's like a
very thin slice kind of cut
so i got to take it get samples take
them to labs and try to see
what type of tools did this how did they
do this with no blood
on the ground and all the soil around it
was dead so i was like well why is it
all dead is that a natural thing
so i took soil samples and took them to
a lab and again i'm outside of my
this is weird to me okay but i i think
there it's a real phenomenon
somebody is killing these animals
something someone
what however you want to say it some
things someone is killing these animals
in a highly
specified technical way that has been
repeated
since the 50s on our fbi has studied it
he has shown me so many reports of these
in association
with discs saucers does this guy
have any association with discs or
saucers or anything no he's just a a
a guy that owns the one they just found
this cattle
weirdly weirdly mutilated somebody
killed it
yeah and he's like is this demonic is
this some sort of satanist thing and i
said i don't think so man this goes back
in history
like i'm looking at the cuts is
specifically
they're very unimpressive what that does
doesn't look like a laser did it or some
incredibly sharp scalpel no it was like
it was like a
serrated one was a serrated tool that's
the thing i'm saying it's like something
that we could do
oh absolutely we'd have to somehow do it
though
on in texas land where the guy would
shoot you in the face if you go and try
to touch one of his cows
that's the other thing no one's ever
been caught never
that's what's weird yeah it's weird it's
frustrating too
i've been to the ranch the skinwalker
ranch in the basin
more than two dozen times i've never
seen anything i've interviewed
the neighbors i've interviewed the
scientists these are phd level guys who
had seen this stuff
a lot of times they have cameras that
fail i mean it's you know you've heard
that story before and this is
very convenient that it happens just
when some giant disk shows up
but it does happen that their car
batteries would die in the same spot
um whatever it was messed with them and
maybe it's humans maybe it is human
technology
but no humans were ever found to be
doing this stuff nids was there for all
those years
they didn't want to tell anybody about
it they shared the information with me
but
you can't publish it there's no real
physical proof
so they just left it there and i had
tried to do a documentary
ended up i talked to him and let me
write a book about it but you know
if if people if you're looking for
physical evidence and solid proof and
they don't happen what is the what's the
primary theory
are there any primary theories of why
they do this to cows
why someone's doing this to cows
you know you need to catch somebody and
ask them i mean you know that's that's
that's really look man it'll be weird
that no one's been caught
investigate the unexplained don't
explain the uninvestigator that's what
he always says
and it's like i wouldn't think i would
ever be interested in this but someone
calls you and say they got a fresh
cattle mutilation
and they you know they're associated
with the ufo phenomena sure i'm gonna
look into it what i find more
interesting is what's happening now
with the the government study that
started here at skinwalker ranch
osap the one that was in the new york
times and and where the information is
going now
these are new times things are starting
to drop to the public
and what what is starting to drop
well the so the skinwalker story
lack of physical evidence though there
may be comes the attention of the
defense intelligence agency this guy
this scientist
who sees it he goes to bigelow they go
visit the property he looks around
he has an experience he's not there 15
or 20 minutes and
something appears inside a house that
only he can see
he doesn't say anything about it he goes
back to washington
meets with harry reid in a skiff in the
capitol
and two other u.s senators he presents
them as the proposal for a study of ufos
and related phenomena not just like atip
looking at
flying saucers that encounter us
military but something more expensive
they put out a contract bigelow bids on
it creates an organization called bass
again puts together a team of experts
50 or 60 employees and they start
studying it they go
around the world they interact with
other governments they get their files
they send out teams to hot spots to try
to figure it out
looking at whether there are connections
between what we call flying saucers
possible aliens and all these other
different phenomena
the program goes on for a couple of
years and somebody yanks the
yanks the funding and get this the
reason that the dia suddenly became
worried
about all this weirdness that was being
reported at skinwalker and elsewhere is
because they thought it was demonic
and they thought if this comes out that
we're studying this weird phenomena
a it's going to end up on the front page
of the new york times which it did
and b we might be invoking satan in here
these were fundamentalist christians
in the pentagon who pulled the money
because they thought it was the devil
i'm not making that up that's hilarious
and the program
it now continues they keep reporting
that it's stopped it hasn't stopped the
us military has been studying ufos
since the beginning in every branch of
our military they continue to do so
and now every time they get caught in a
lie so it is continuing tell them about
it it is continuing so
uh all stops money was taken away but
the atip
program which is what lou elizondo
headed up that looked just at
military ufo encounters continued
pentagon says it was ended it did not
it continued for a couple of years and
after the new york times story comes out
and
creates this furor it got funding and it
now has a structured organization
and it is looking into cases where the
u.s military
sees these things and off the coast of
the virginia
they've been seeing this stuff i think
fraver talked about it when he was here
these
beach balls with cubes inside of them
and they were sitting there for hours
off the coast right where our warplanes
would go out for training exercises
as if they wanted to be seen and it went
on there were 70 or 80
witnesses during 2015-2016 pilots
some of them were willing to talk about
it some weren't it continues to this day
now the program is on more solid footing
now
congress has been informed and they want
to expand it and
get more information we are told the new
york times is working on another
follow-up story
to look into reports of what lazar said
crash retrievals reverse engineering
the existence of these meta materials
bits and pieces that
grand pods stashed in a barn somewhere
whether it's roswell or other alleged
crashes
they're taking it seriously to figure
out if there's something about these
materials that we could not have have
created
so the bas program the asap program
created a baseline of what we know about
the state of our technology right now in
different disciplines
lyft and and propulsion things of that
sort they commissioned 38 papers
that would be the baseline for what the
state of human knowledge was
in 2009 and um and those papers were
were published on a an internal
department of defense uh website but
they've never been made public
six of them have now leaked out and i
brought along two more for you that have
not been made public
um so these are these are like
scientific reports based on the
government study of ufos
okay so they commissioned these papers
only a handful have been released to the
public
george happens to have a couple more so
you can
you're gonna be the first person outside
the program other than me to see it
so what is it they're called a durd this
is a defense intelligence reference
document
this paper is on meta materials so how
you can engineer
existing earth materials where you could
duplicate what you're seeing up there
none of these papers two of them
actually mention aliens or ufos
they're strictly on what the state of
our knowledge is or was as of 2009
and they reference aliens and ufos only
two of the papers do
and how do they reference it well
there's one of the papers that looks at
the physical effects of people that come
into contact with these unknown craft
and it's sort of like the effects of
radiation or microwaves
there are physical effects hundreds of
cases that have been investigated and
that's what that paper
looks at and that's already out there
yeah the harm that is done to the body
what they call
close proximity to a uap which is a ufo
there are known effects to the human
body that are
horrible and there was a study that
focused on the witnesses they do know
how close encounters like military
people
and then how it negatively impacted
their body so each of these reports as
he obtains them or as people find them
they're very
illuminating to what our government
knows there was one that looked at
how you would track a hypersonic vehicle
traveling through space how difficult
would it be now it doesn't say ufos but
it's looking at
things that really travel fast that are
coming in from space into our atmosphere
how would you track that now when that
paper was written in 2009
we didn't have hypersonic weapons now
the russians claim they've got them
now it's very timely because we're in a
rush to develop those things so that was
one of the papers that i made
public last year and i interviewed the
engineering professor who wrote it
he wasn't writing about ufos he was
writing about the state of knowledge
about hypersonic weapon systems back
then it's a similar thing for
meta materials that's what this this
paper is is how would you engineer
materials so you could
travel through space that would have say
you shoot it with the microwaves
and it could develop certain special
properties so just to put into context
maybe
because you know here's the deal um our
government has now admitted there are
ufos
that that's the world we're living in
their unidentified objects or craft
that seem to outpace outmaneuver
actively jam our radar systems
even go over our military installations
of high sensitivity their incursions
all of this is now said it's a different
world we're living in
however the next thing that people are
talking about now is
well we also have materials we call them
meta materials
materials associated with ufo craft they
might even go as far as to say
we have whole materials craft
from somewhere else so when they're
saying we have materials associated from
crafts are they saying that they
have a crash yes
who was a physicist who worked with
bigelow on both
nids and bass made a presentation in las
vegas in
uh june of 2018 where he says yeah we've
got these materials
and we're trying to figure out where
they came from and how they were
engineered because some of them appear
to be multi-layered
that are beyond what is known
engineering capabilities of humans
it looks like they would have had been
made in say zero gravity of space
and we don't have any manufacturing
plants up there he
implied that they came from crashes
doesn't mean it's a ufo from
zeta reticuli it's crashed from
somewhere and we don't know whose it is
so they're trying to figure out whether
we can duplicate it or not
and they got a bunch of samples and uh
have you seen any of this no i haven't
seen it
bigelow and have you seen i've seen what
people claim so the army now has these
meta materials that were famously put in
through
actually the coast-to-coast show it was
called arts parts i told you this last
time
i did i was able to obtain them briefly
and have five scientists from new mexico
that i knew
material scientists physicists
interrogate as they say the samples for
numerous days
i don't believe that i had access to the
best equipment
we didn't find anything extraordinary
other people have so right now the army
so but when you say you didn't find
anything extraordinary did you find
anything ordinary
no they weren't ordinary these are the
materials here that's the exact p
one of the exact pieces that i had in my
hands and and worked on
with my team and i filmed it all but
right now because of uh ttsa
they've made a deal with the army and i
think the army has these parts
but i feel like we're missing that the
big note here the big note is
a few years ago ufos are still laughable
military doesn't look after that turns
out we have
programs that do i'm suspecting and
maybe you can talk more about it
that the next piece of information is
that there are reverse engineering
programs
which will then make everybody have to
look at lazar's story a little bit
differently once
again if we admit that we are trying to
reverse engineer
either materials or actual craft from
somewhere else
intelligently designed metals or craft
from somewhere else if there are crash
retrieval programs
for vehicles we don't know where they're
from that's going to make me look at
bob's story
even more even more differently right
but it's not a big if
i mean if if they've it's an interesting
time
it is but i mean there's no indication
that they're willing to
discuss some retrieved craft right yeah
i think that's a heavy lift so
supposedly the new york times is working
on that story
i think it'd be pretty hard for them
yeah they are they've been asking people
about this stuff but i mean to get that
into print to get it past their editors
that's a hard
deal just extraterrestrial material from
the bottom of a wedge-shaped craft in
the late 1940s made of 26
alternating layers one to four microns
dark
bismuth is that how you say that there's
my bismuth
and 100 to 200 microns of silver
magnesium zinc alloy each of the six
pieces received from the us army source
were formed with a curvature that
tapered
so basically they're saying for there's
no process that we know of that would
create
this alloy layered in that type of layer
system i actually have a piece out about
this
isn't that kind of how they did samurai
swords ooh that's cool
yeah i'm not sure that this is alien of
any kind
but it is of unknown origin and um
well jacques vale has like 20 as i said
last jack [ __ ] valet he's got like 27
samples of things associated with crash
retrieval
so if anybody has an archive of this
stuff that's being scientifically
interrogated right now
and his studies do show isotopic ratios
that are not
from this earth so he's confident with
his research
my big point he's confident with his
research of what
well you'd have to talk you should talk
with jacques but he's right but what is
he confident of that you can say
that he has that he has alloys that came
from
ufo crashes or run off has anybody
independently analyzed those things
yeah he's got a whole he says yeah
whole teams of people well how come this
isn't like public knowledge why isn't
this in the new york times
you got to get you got to get you got to
talk with jacques whether you have him
as a guest or not you guys should talk
about how old is jacques now he's
getting he's getting up there because
he's in his yeah just um here's i would
probably have to go to him right with a
hazmat
he's a strong dude where is he san
francisco specifically no yeah
what's the address yeah here's the thing
that this program is ongoing
it doesn't have to find aliens uh there
are legitimate national security reasons
to be looking at who these
who's flying these craft these things
are still being seen
over our military installations and our
our
pentagon wants to know who's flying them
and that's a perfectly legitimate
inquiry regardless a little green men no
one wants to say they're
at the pentagon that we're investigating
ufos and aliens
uh they're just investigating where
these things come from are they a threat
can we duplicate that technology if the
russians or the chinese get this stuff
before we
we do if they can do what the tic tac
did it's a game changer
so they want to know how whose it is
and how we can duplicate it and that is
a perfectly legitimate inquiry whether
they're
aliens or not what is the most
compelling piece of physical evidence to
you
i don't know i mean i don't know that we
have physical evidence
other than if bob lazar's story is true
we've got craft out there that we didn't
make
i mean the idea that we have stuff that
we're reverse engineering to figure out
how it was made
that would be that would be the clincher
i remember reading about jane allen
heineck
when he was uh running project blue book
now he initially started it with the
intent to debunk all of these stories
and come up with some sort of uh
rational explanation that you could pass
off the general public
swamp gas as time went on he became a
believer
and i thought that was really
fascinating and then after project blue
book closed
he was very open and public about it
i'll give you one of his cases from
project blue book it's april 18
1962. the original explanation is it's a
meteor
it comes into a atmosphere over cuba it
goes all the way up the east coast of
the u.s
when it gets to new york it turns left
it takes a left turn
goes all the way across the united
states at a couple of places it slows
down
it's picked up on radar jets are chased
after it they can't catch it it keeps on
going
it gets to utah there's a little town
called eureka and it lands
lands in utah knocks out the power to
the whole town
then it takes off again that's a heck of
a meteor it gets over near mesquite
nevada and explodes
and this thing the explosion was seen
for hundreds of miles i saw it in las
vegas and reno
i had interviewed a team that went out
there to look for pieces they thought it
might have been an airplane that
exploded
supposedly never found it a meteor that
travels
takes a left turn slows down lands takes
off again that's like no meteor i ever
heard of but
jl and hynix team from blue book in
their files that's how they explained it
away
the the best evidence for me because
look i'm just curious about this
this is just one of those places where
all the answers aren't there
i want to know man so the the best
evidence for me because i
asked that same question to everybody
it's it's the fact that we're being lied
to
that alone we can prove that we can
prove that our government intelligence
agencies have
actively partake in lying to us
about the ufo subject that there are
craft of unknown origin that fly with
impunity in our airspace
globally and throughout history and so
the fact that they are
lying and have been lying that makes me
i'm like why are you lying to me then
i want to find out so for me that's the
greatest evidence that there's
scientific studies
on this stuff and everybody's hushed the
[ __ ] hush about it
why is it like north korea had
leapfrogged us 50 years ago so all of a
sudden you know that's our enemy
i mean who is operating this craft that
comes in from outer space
drops down to sea level docks like the
tic tac was docking
with a uso an underwater craft
and it outpaces our military jets you've
got to be dead
to not be curious about this so that's
the greatest evidence to me is the fact
where
we've been lied to is an american
population and we're just starting to
peel back layers
that this [ __ ] is real and our
military's worried about it well if we
haven't been lied to at the very least
they haven't felt it
well if they don't have real evidence
other than this stuff that we're
discussing if this is all they have
i don't know what they would tell the
general public totally also part of the
problem
yes what do you say you know
as i said this is an amazing time we're
getting closer to knowing what the
government knows but that doesn't mean
we'd have an answer
right i don't think they know either
that was always my take on it was like
why would they talk to the government
like if you came from another planet
and you were looking at us as weird
territorial chimps with nuclear weapons
what would you why would you pick one
group
and then talk to them as opposed to just
the general public why would you elected
leaders would they really be important
to you
like it doesn't make any sense at all
yeah i never really bought into the
stories that there had been a formal
meetings or anything i think the
government is as clueless as the rest of
us they have more information
because they have the sensors to collect
it they have a giant apparatus
sensors that detect things coming in and
out of space and radar
somewhere there's a giant pile of
information that we haven't been able to
see
but it doesn't mean that it answers the
question this this thing has been with
human
humans throughout history and it's
always just tantalizingly out of reach
you know used to be golden shields and
that it'd be swords and
flaming chariots and now it's flying
saucers and it looks like technology
that maybe we could someday achieve
but it's always out of reach and i think
it will remain out of reach well there's
one thing that bob talked about from
some of the
the documents that he had been given
when he was working at s4
was that they had actually taken a part
in
engineering human beings and that is
to me like if you if you wanted to say
like what
what's what's the thing that's going to
get people to roll their eyes the most
well you would say well that the aliens
came down here and they they
they got a hold of the lower hominids
and they accelerated the evolutionary
process and they created human beings
people a lot of people go get the [ __ ]
out of here that's crazy
but if you look at people one of the
weird things about people is how much we
vary we're so different
like not like any other animal like
other than dogs
and dogs are the way they are because
we've [ __ ] with them
because we've manipulated them we are
the dogs of
the rest of the world you know if you
really think about it
we're so different than every other
primate there's not even anything close
to us
and i know there were some other human
species
you know was the how do you say it to
denovians
there's neanderthals homo floriensis
which was those
little hobbit people that have been a
bunch of other humanoids
but nothing that came close to what we
are
and if you look at ancient
uh ancient primates and us the leap
between them and us is so quick the
doubling of the human brain size over a
period of two million years is just
bonkers
like they don't know why they don't know
what happened they have no idea but if
if that really is what happened
if they said listen they're gonna get
there but we can help
like would you let's just jump in
because these things like look chimps
are still chimps right they're still
murdering each other they're still
tearing monkeys apart and eating them
alive
they're still doing the same things
they've been doing for thousands and
thousands of years whereas we're living
in condominiums and
watching cable you know it's like
whatever has happened to humans has
happened
so the the the advancement is
so unique it's so different than any
other animal
if we really have been visited since the
beginning of time since history if all
those
biblical stories and all the stories
from the bhagavad-gita
and all these ancient texts that do talk
about vimanas and flying crafts and
beings that come down from upon high if
all that
really is aliens intervening
with the the biological evolution of
human beings
how [ __ ] weird are we you know i mean
i mean if you think about how weird we
are period i mean maybe that would kind
of explain it
that we're some stupid science
experiment
well you know people say i want
disclosure
i want to know we're ready we can handle
it are you sure
you can't handle the truth i mean are
you sure you can handle it because
we don't know exactly what it is that
can be disclosed but what if it turns
out that we're an agricultural product
you know that we are being harvested for
something or we're being allowed to
to breed and kind of a science
experiment let's see where this goes
and then when it's time to end the
experiment i mean i'm not sure people
can handle it look at
how they've handled covet well if you
would think about
if if aliens coming down and
interfering with weapon systems and
interfering with nuclear
launch codes and things along those
lines like
if you think about the uptick in alien
sightings and activity post hiroshima
and nagasaki
that would kind of make sense like all
right these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they've gotten to a point where they can
do some really crazy [ __ ] and they
literally might ruin this whole thing
they figured out how to light the match
like if you if you take this uh
primate this animal and you
embed it with the superior or
at least more uh evolutionary advanced
genetics then you manipulate it to a
point where you make it
weaker but smarter far more curious and
obsessed with innovation let me just
leave it there
well it's just a matter of time like how
much is that time is it a thousand years
is it ten thousand years
over time they're going to figure out
some crazy [ __ ] because they're just
going to keep working together
like they do and then boom bombs go off
and like all right we got a signal
these crazy [ __ ] have figured out how
to split the atom
we got to get down there and and and
keep a closer eye on these people
i'm open to that possibility of that
being the case i mean it's it's weird
it's the craziest idea
no there's crazier ones being put out
today just like the big bang is the
craziest idea and
we all agree on that that's the craziest
thing the whole universe came out of
nothing right
smaller than the head of a pin
instantaneously creates everything you
see in the night sky
okay the technology that shows up that
may be reverse engineered or craft or
bits and pieces
you know i sometimes equate it with
let's throw us
we're aliens let's throw a cell phone
into a chimpanzee cage here have at it
see how you do for a while
i don't know that we're ever going to
figure this stuff out well more than
that it would be
like let's let's take a chimpanzee
and let's manipulate its brain and leave
them with a bunch of tools
you know give it give it some things and
see what it comes up with
and then come back and try again i mean
maybe neanderthal was like well you know
they're not going to get any
further past this like this this project
we need to scrap
it start with something new i don't
think that's not look
we do weird [ __ ] to animals i mean we
study them
we you know i was just talking to a
friend of mine about zoos about
how bummed out i was when i went to this
wolf sanctuary
because everybody's like oh it's amazing
you get to see these wolves that they've
rescued
i got there i saw a bunch of castrated
wolves that were living in prison
i didn't think it was cool at all it
freaked me out i i got really depressed
i i think what you look at what we're
willing to do
to chimps i mean i remember going to um
i i forget maybe it was denver i forget
where it was the zoo
but there was a zoo where there was this
monkey that was in a cage that was
screaming
just screaming like he was going crazy
it was a small cage
and people were walking around he's like
just and i was like he's probably going
mad this is not how a monkey's supposed
to live they're supposed to be in the
jungle in the wild
you know harvesting food and living with
other monkeys they're not supposed to be
alone in a cage where these other weird
primates walk by and stare at it it
just overwhelms all of its defense
systems and
survival systems we're willing to do
that to things that we know or at least
slightly intelligent like what would be
willing to do
weirder more advanced experiments
to primates to create us and how do you
tell a population
if you do study ufos as the government
you find out okay [ __ ] there are craft
and they're coming in
they're probably studying us like how do
you [ __ ] tell people that like how
are people gonna react
and the way that it's so
compartmentalized that's been the best
proof to me
as well if i've talked to somebody who's
worked on
a project and they're like all i saw was
a super capacitor
in 1974 and i know this was not
something we made
he was told nothing else he just saw a
technology that
was more efficient than anything he had
ever seen
so the idea that people are funneling
this information
whoever is funneling it and protecting
this information
as we see how osap and atip didn't get
special
access permission that's a special type
of program
they knew about crash retrieval programs
so they said we want to compare notes
and information with other ufo projects
they were denied access yeah the door
was slammed in their face
when they tried to ask that senator reid
it was senate majority leader
had asked for permission to create it as
an sap special access program
so they could get access to other
goodies and they said no
other retrieval programs material
programs stuff that
bob has talked about so just the fact
that it's it's so
hidden even within its own mechanism
that they won't allow this scientific
team to work on this
project it tells me as robbie says
something's up i mean
something's up well that was one of the
weirder things about
bob's description of areas4 about how
compartmentalized everything was
about you know one group worked on
metallurgy the other group worked on
propulsion and they didn't share
information
it pissed him off so bad man well it was
what the way he described best
is that scientific research the way
you progress is they everybody works
together
and it doesn't happen in a vacuum so
they were literally trying to do
scientific research
without the scientific method they were
trying to
withhold information from them and only
get them to concentrate on one
aspect of this project without the whole
group coming together and getting some
sort of a comprehensive understanding of
what these things are bob said he wasn't
the most qualified
person to do the job either that freaked
him out and he didn't have the right
materials even well i think they
probably
if let's assume they are alien
spacecraft they probably knew that
no one was qualified they probably knew
that we did we just really have no idea
especially
if they had been working on these things
for decades like bob
assumed they had been they probably had
gone through the best scientists that
they could
and they realized look no one has any
idea let's get this
out of the box weirdo who puts jet
engines and hondas
let's get some some straight look
there's a lot of very strange people out
there that are incredibly intelligent
that you know might not fit into your
standard educational
you know bundle or category
of research scientist or whatever you
might might just be a weirdo who likes
to shoot guns and
make hydrogen-powered corvettes maybe
that's the kind of guy
that's going to see something that maybe
other folks haven't seen yet
i think that's entirely possible it's
also possible that they used him to
discredit the idea of crash retrievals
forever
you know let's bring this guy in show
him some stuff let him spout it out
then we'll we'll cut his legs off yeah
but the problem is the
reason why he spouted it out was
you know it was so clear that they had
nothing to do with that
it was his wife having an affair and he
had top secret clearance
because he has top secret clearance
they're monitoring all of his phone
calls
they find out that the wife is banging
her flight instructor and so they say
liz this guy's going to be
unstable we can't have him work there
anymore they suspend his working
privileges and he freaks out
and then he takes people to see the
crowd the launch sites
he takes a look they do this at a
certain time period every week i'm going
to take you down there he takes his
friends down there
they get busted they get arrested it's
just too the
the actual verifiable facts
of his being caught the whole phone call
thing the fact that his wife was having
the affair
there's no way they're playing that kind
of 4d chess this is a [ __ ] government
they're too goofy
if i found out that bob lazar was lying
to the world i would be the first person
to tell you there's no reason i wouldn't
that was the whole reason i got
interested that's why i contacted george
back in the day
i wanted to know if he was [ __ ]
making it up with bob and i
i'll attest to you for whatever you
value my opinion at i have
been with bob in his life met
everybody his family the closer you get
to his inner circle
the more you understand that he's
telling the truth
and never once have i found something
where i'm like you're a [ __ ] liar
never once yeah he's he it's a weird
thing
like the only thing that people kept
pointing to in the podcast was that he
was getting migraines
but dude he had migraines he had
migraines earlier today i mean
it wasn't any you could tell he would
stop
and he he would wince and you know he
just didn't like the idea that he was
going to do this thing
that he knew that millions and millions
of people are going to see him talk
about this for hours and hours
and he knew it was all going to come
back up again all the investigation all
the people [ __ ] with them all the
attention that he had avoided another
important point is this is not a guy who
profited off of this story
no this guy told this story for 31 years
and didn't profit off of it
the migraine might have been the
mcdonald's his wife was furious at me
because when i brought him over i was
like just get some in your stomach man
again so i think it was bad food
but he could have been that and the
pressure but the pressure the pressure
was deep because
you know he didn't know you he didn't
know if you know you're just gonna you
know start asking him about
um you know his wife cheating on him and
you know it's like
it's stressful man oh listen i get it
man i mean that was one of the good
reasons uh
why we had dinner the night before with
my buddy andrew schultz and i brought
andrew along too because he's a really
smart guy and i said just
just please just pay attention to this
[ __ ] tell me what you say
because if you see some [ __ ] you see
some weirdness let me know what do you
say
nothing he said i don't know because
that guy's telling the truth that is
[ __ ]
crazy you know because andrew is a comic
but a really good one and a really smart
guy
yeah so his i just wanted you know again
outside the box have some guy who's not
obsessed with ufos at all
have him come and you know and andrew
asked a bunch of questions
andy was at the bar before when bob and
i arrived we go up to the bar
i didn't know who andrew was right and
then joe walks in hey andrew and he had
been sitting right next to it so joe was
putting spies out that was a good move
but you know that it's so frustrating
it's it's fun
and i think i would have stopped but
george been doing this 30 years it's
like
you always get one step forward and look
we all want to know if this stuff is
true but the weight of the evidence is
so heavy now with the government
programs and
everything that you've been involved
with it's just an exciting time
and i think i learned more in in this
last year
than all the time before and i think
that that's going to continue i don't
think we're all of a sudden going to say
okay this doesn't matter anymore
if this is real yeah i'm not counting on
any answers anytime soon we may know
more about what the government knows but
that's not the ultimate answer i mean
what if it turns out
these are not aliens they live here
there's some other intelligence that we
can't see
they can reach in like rats in a
in a cage and pull us out once in a
while or do experiments to us and
it's their planet and we're living in
this tiny slice of reality and don't
realize what's going on around us
there's a ufo uh ufo there's a ufc
fighter a woman named angela hill she's
a badass
and her grandfather is barney hill
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i didn't know
until after the podcast her and i did a
podcast together just talking about her
fighting career
and then at the end of it she goes oh
there's one thing i forgot to bring up
this is like after the show's over i'm
like what
how did you forget to bring that up that
is so crazy
her grandfather is one of the
most important characters in the history
of ufo abduction
betty and barney hill who are a couple
in new hampshire
yes maine or new hampshire new hampshire
and they get abducted
and through hypnotic regression tell
this crazy story
of the lost time their car stops these
this ufo shows up and then they have
this classic
abduction story that we have heard time
and time again
and i had this conversation with someone
where they were saying do you believe in
these ufo abductions
and i said i don't i don't believe in
them but i don't not believe in them
either
i don't i i just keep a blank slate with
this
because he and he their take was like
wouldn't you think more people would
talk about it more thing i'll go why
would they do it that often
i go how many unique occurrences would
have to take place before it would be
common knowledge
how many times would people have to be
abducted before you would believe
and what would they get out of these
abductions and look
we we know what we're willing to do with
chimpanzees or gorillas or any other
primate orangutans that we find in the
wild
they run experiments on them they
capture them they do things to them all
the time
why wouldn't something that's infinitely
more intelligent than us
abduct to folks that are driving
somewhere betty and barney hill why
wouldn't they you know why wouldn't they
experiment on them there they are right
there these are people that don't want
attention i mean it's a
interracial couple back in the was it
50s or 60s
it was probably in a lot of part i mean
it wasn't until
i found out until 1966 or 68 like while
i was alive
that interracial couples were allowed to
marry in the entire country
so betty and barney hill it's kind of
funny when i'm looking at barney he does
kind of look like
angela oh you see the genetics i don't
know maybe i'm just looking in
the unsolved mysteries one on abductions
the new unsolved mysteries reboot
no oh dude great case the other case
that fascinates me besides this one but
that one
surely fascinates me because it's the
original but travis walter yeah
yes yeah that's a weird one man it's a
it's a solid one too i mean i've met
travis a few times and uh
his story like lazar's does not change
there are additional witnesses what he
went through
is comparable to bob i mean he was
called a liar and
basically i think his friends were
accused of murdering him and that's a
solid case
i mean it's a it's a really weird one
too another great case so i met two of
the girls um
salma and liesel and remember that
school where like 80 kids or something
would get some parts wrong 80 kids saw
these craft come down and the bbc came
the next day with dr john mack head of
harvard psychiatry
and he's the one who wrote that book
abduction yeah i read this is what got
him like
so these kids see this craft come down
south africa
and uh at the aerial school and i
actually got to spend a weekend with two
of the primary witnesses one that was
three feet away from she's telling me
there was a being there
when you hear what happened to them now
the bbc did film the next day
you did have dr john mack going and and
testing all the kids and trying to see
consensus what they saw
but when i met these two women later in
life
i i can't dismiss what they're telling
me it's like you telling me
you went to the grocery store why am i
going to doubt you man that's how
matter of fact they are about it they
don't know what they saw
but they know they know exactly what
they saw they just don't know the
implications of it well john mack
experienced a lot of blow back from that
book
oh you know you're talking about a guy
who's uh was he employed at harvard yeah
at the time he's head of hard
psychiatry yeah and so he writes this
book about ufo abductions
and um i actually found out but from my
friend maura
who worked with me on news radio with
dave foley she actually was reading the
book she's like this is right up your
alley
she goes it's so crazy like i i didn't
know what to think somebody recommended
it
but along the way she's like these
stories are so similar it's
crazy like there's all these different
people that don't know each other from
all over the world
that have really similar stories like if
this thing is happening
again how would anyone know and how many
times would they have to do it and
why would it be common knowledge like if
if they have the ability to come here
from another galaxy or another solar
system
and they can penetrate our defenses and
hover over a place and abduct someone
and run experiments on them and
put them back there with some sort of a
distorted memory
which seems to be part of the story and
many of them that
their memory is at least partially wiped
and they come back very confused
like how many of those would take place
before we would all know about it
i mean you they wouldn't have to do it
that often there's 300 million people
and they do it once a week
who the [ __ ] is going to know well again
how are you going to hear about it
what's the what's proof right what is
the level of proof right for
those cases this uh phenomena is elusive
right it wants to show us glimpses of
itself and glimpses of other realities
but it doesn't want us to be able to
prove it it's as if it's trying to tell
us
it's like a learning curve you know that
reality isn't what it used to be that
it's way more complicated than you might
think it is
that's sort of like what we got out of
the ranch is that it's putting all these
different weird phenomena together
when you can't really prove any of them
it's it's trying to tell you something
so what can you learn from what's your
take on whitley streiber
it's it's a mix i think he's a brilliant
guy and
i i think he did have some experiences i
don't know that
the experience is continued you know you
get mixed signals from him
the fact that he is a great novelist a
horror novelist complicates it
complicates it he thinks about this
stuff on a different level you know
it used to be we all thought it saw that
alien on the cover of his book communion
and
and figured it was a space alien from
some other planet and he's on a whole
different level about what they might be
now what does he think they are
like in essence gods i mean
jacques valet had said if you can
manipulate space-time
if you can create your own gravity like
the craft that bob was talking about
you could be from other planets other
solar systems other times you could be
time travelers
you could be from other dimensions or
all of the above
like dr john mack had suggested that
abductions
and these strange experiences in
connection with them suggest that we're
part of a galactic
neighborhood a cosmic neighborhood
multi-dimensional reality that we
haven't got our heads around yet
and that it's important for our ultimate
survival that we figure it out
george i just you know
george has been remember he is a
journalist that broke mob
stories corruption stories political
corruption i mean just last year i mean
this guy has been doing this for 30
something years ufos has defined him
because the world at large has defined
him by the ufos that's because of the
stigma now of course he's made
lots of headway and done all he does the
coast show like our bell
but what he's doing now is kind of cool
after 30 years
of studying this and filming with people
on news you get to drop
12 seconds one minute in a news report
he has an
akashic record of everybody ever
involved with claims about this stuff
throughout the last 30 years
and he's been dumping it all online
so all of his collective wisdom over the
years of what could this [ __ ] be
he is now starting to release those
archives and so this is for me it's a
very exciting time because
like the lazar interviews there's so
much more out there now that
he had under his station where do you
keep that george it's called
mysterywire.com
it's a i work for klaus i'm still part
of the i team but
since the beginning of the year i'm
focusing most of our attention on that
producing new content but all this stuff
that i've stashed
at home and elsewhere is going up on
there dr john mack will be on there
eventually because i got to interview
him too while he's still alive
um and he was hit by a car right what is
this jamie what is that
new area 51 photographs taken by private
pilots oh that was pretty cool yeah they
flew over papoose like you know it's
like you're allowed to do that
no you can you can get clearance to get
by and have a really good camera but
here's what's so funny it's like people
that aren't convinced will never be
convinced
they said oh there's new photos of
papoose lake and we don't see an
installation
and i'm like oh you don't see an
installation that was built
to not be seen from the air
okay i mean it's if people don't want to
you know follow this [ __ ] or understand
it they're always going to
see whatever they want to see are you
following me yeah okay
i was in the vacuum they're very looking
at me i was like well you're having an
argument with someone who's not there
oh okay you know you're like arguing so
you're not seeing it yeah
no one's here yeah my point is it's just
i'm
i can't bang my head against the wall
because i don't know what the real truth
is
george is it was it a struggle to talk
about
uh ufos and yet maintain a serious
career as an investigative journalist
very much so uh you know i had the
support of my news director
and the station at the time and you know
they were encouraged by the reaction
from our audience it was
it was big and then it expanded and went
all over the
world but i think they worried that i
was going too far down the rabbit hole
so i had to be careful i mean for me it
is not my religion i'm not chasing this
because i've got a
hole in my heart where god should be
it's a story it's always been a story
and so i try to be careful
and not commit to a position it's space
aliens it's interdimensionals
i'm following what evidence there is i'm
listening to the witness testimony
and trying to figure it out and and over
the years you know i have been
all over the world to chase this down in
the end
a lot of the answers of the best
information was right in las vegas
because of
bigelow and the organizations that he
founded
all that expertise came right into my
backyard and then harry reid
being the sponsor to uh the program that
became atip
i mean uh i've been fortunate to be a
fly on the wall
and and to gain their trust and it it's
tricky you know it's tricky because
so many people find this to be crazy and
ridiculous and
whenever i do a story un not related to
ufos it's about some crooked politician
or cops or something like that
and people are mad at me which happens
often they bring up ufos you know
that's the ufo guy how seriously can it
be
yeah but but i've had the support of my
employer and i'm thankful for that
and uh you know i get to be a little
more creative on coast to coast because
it's a four-hour show and
and you can let people go i don't have
to be judgmental about it
when i'm reporting as a regular news
story i have to be more careful about
what i include in it but yeah we're
putting all that stuff up and uh
it's been a fun ride and there's a lot
of times i just want to walk away from
it like you i get disgusted by it
yeah have you have you noticed in your
world the world of investigative
journalism that
attitudes and opinions have changed
about ufos
very much so i think you know i'll go
back to the new york times story that
changed so much
so i had known that stuff and when i
found out they were going to do it
i had known about the the program that
was underway i said hey why don't i get
to do this
because uh i've known about all this
time i've kept quiet about it because
that was my agreement
i'm going to do this story they said no
this is bigelow
senator reid and tom delong had asked me
don't do that if you do it
the new york times said they'll back out
and so i sort of
i don't want to say took one for the
team but i realized i'm not the new york
times they were
gently letting me know i'm the ufo
reporter if i do it
nobody's going to pay attention to it if
the new york times does it
then everybody does pay attention to it
and they did they did that story then
the washington post and politico
all the new networks did stories of
press all over the world
it is now acceptable for reporters to
dig into it
you have to be careful there are still
liars and scammers out there who will
mislead you but there is information
that can be pursued
by reporters and and i think that's made
all the difference it made congress
more comfortable with exploring it and
our world is different from
um than it was two and a half years ago
yeah i think the the people that were in
control
of this stuff also in the 60s and 70s
they're not around anymore
so you're dealing with now people that
are in government
involved in the military that grew up in
the age of the internet
and they have a different perspective
perspective about these subjects
of the free flow of information they see
everything is there
why is this why is anything i think
younger people
just have a different perception about
ufos in general
i mean i i think that you're you're not
dealing with the post 1947 people
that were uh you know talking about it
back in the day
where they and also the attitude of the
way the military
and the government interface with the
public i mean that they
they could come up with the most
ridiculous deception like the roswell
case is one of my favorite ones i mean i
used to have a bit about it but how
crazy it is that
they say and they printed in the paper
we've recovered a down
saucer and then the next day is a
weather balloon
you don't know the difference between a
spacecraft from another dimension
or another planet or a weather balloon
that was made in ohio
well the same question now dave fravor
doesn't know the difference between a
tic tac
this weird craft and a seagull or
something you know he won't engage those
insane you know arguments he just won't
do it he's a fighter pie doesn't give a
[ __ ]
well it's uh the other thing that he was
talking about that we didn't really get
to is that
that thing not only was recognizing that
he was there but it was
jamming it was doing some sort of active
jam
an act of war this is the other paper i
i wanted to tell you about it it does
mention aliens so it's a
it's it is a recalculation of am i in
trouble for having no
no they're not classified it says
unclassified it just hasn't been
released out of this room right now
it just recalculates how likely it is
there are alien civilizations in our
solar system or
likely so it's uh about the fermi
paradox it's certainly taking
place the drake equation so they've done
this years ago about
they tried to figure out how many
planets are out there how many are
uninhabited this is a
reworking of the calculations and again
i can't read it
intelligence reference document and
introduction to the
statistical drake equation so this is
something that they
they created for the defense department
yeah so they could get an understanding
yeah what the baseline of our
information is about
all those different topics i told you
about and then this one is
how likely is it that we have galactic
neighbors and how close might they be
yeah num the key question how far are
they
it comes to an answer it's like 30 pages
into that but you're
the first person outside the program wow
to see it you better address it
sure this is okay yeah it feels like i'm
gonna get visited
that's um yeah well how far do they
think they are
i hope they dig it up for you and again
i'm
one of the reasons i become a journalist
is so i don't have to do math so
um that's one of the cool things now
that's happening
is um because of the new york times
article and and really because
you know you had bob on and come out of
favor people are talking about this and
the zeitgeist
i've had more people serious people
come forward to me in the last year of
my life
than ever before and it includes soccer
moms and just people that just
post the documentary yes ever since
the lazar documentary you know and and
people found out that i kept my word to
fragrant didn't
tell his story new york times told it i
kept all that
you know people started to trust me with
hey we can keep his mouth shut if he
needs to
people have come forward to me and drove
since the lazar movie
and of course it's like soccer moms and
people that just say
i don't want to be known i just want
somebody to hear this because my husband
would think i'm crazy let me just tell
you what happened to me and i'm out of
your life and what are they telling you
i mean joe it's um everything you can
imagine from
seeing craft that are right there
right in front of them to you know
abduction stories which i don't get into
because it's too crazy for me
but they're reporting sightings
encounters
all ufo stuff that's why they call me
they don't call me for other stuff right
but also very serious people people that
have worked or do work
within our military and say i had an
encounter
i there was an incursion i know george
has dealt with this for 30 years
it's just it's just new for me that the
the amount of people coming forward to
me and telling me their stories and
giving me documents and stuff like that
i got to be careful because a lot of
it's got to be [ __ ] right
but a good handful of it is power a lot
of it is you know
it's um like bait they're really
discredited
yeah um do you think is that what you
think or do you think it's just crazy
people
it's crazy people and some of it might
be more organized than that at the
reach of your show joe since when bob
was on there
i know what what happened to jeremy as a
result of it i get
a little bit of the blow back because
people are interested in the topic but
it's amazing how uh much of an impact
it's had
to kindle people's interests not only in
that story but in others
on the general topic by the way this
paper
says with a 75 probability the nearest
extraterrestrial civilization is located
in between
1361 and 3 979 light years from us
so there there you go wow and the way
they travel that ain't [ __ ]
no that's so and that's lunchtime and
that's such the important part of it
remember we're talking about
non-reactionary
propulsion systems everybody like 10
years ago everybody's like okay
the universe is vast there's probably an
intelligent life forms out in the soul
in
in the solar systems in the universe but
they ain't coming here right
but then you look at what bob said and
how gravity wave amplification would
and then you look at the testimony of
like commander favor and how those craft
move
you see how the gimbal moves and then
you start thinking well
distance doesn't matter anymore that's
just us saying physicists we're right
well hold on physics has changed as our
understanding has changed
so now we're looking at a propulsion
system where distance doesn't matter
man that brings us all much [ __ ]
closer together if any of this is true
yeah if any of this is true
this i mean there was a lot of naysayers
back in the day that were quote unquote
ufo experts that had more traditional
ideas of how they traveled here like
stanton friedman
he had his hot potato theory that they
just did it in short bursts like very
fast travel and short bursts so you
could tolerate
but if they and he didn't believe in bob
lazar too but i always felt like there
was some weirdness there
like ufo
guys and researchers are so used to
people being full of [ __ ]
that everyone but them is full of [ __ ]
right and that's what i felt like with
stanton when stanton would discredit
bob's uh
education pass and all these different
things i'd be like yeah but i don't know
i don't think you know him i don't think
you talk to him i don't think you get in
the room i think
like if we just just empty out empty out
all your
predisposed notions of who the guy is
and look at it
what if he's telling the truth like what
if he's telling the truth does that
place actually exist area s4 yes
does he have some weird knowledge of it
yes did he really work at los alamos lab
yes
did people who worked there remember him
yes
does he know how to navigate the
building from the inside
yes was there a [ __ ] article in the
newspaper where he built a [ __ ] jet
car and it said he was a physicist at
los alamos lab
yes these things are piling up stanton i
wish you were alive
i wish you were alive because he was a
really smart guy who was also obsessed
with ufos but
again these ufo experts all believe that
everyone else is full of [ __ ]
i had a 20-year dialogue with stan
friedman and i respect the hell out of
him because he really
plodded away and really plowed the
ground on the topic in general and tried
to make it respectable
but he had a blind spot about bob we had
multiple
face-to-face conversations and exchanged
letters over the years
did you ever say what if he was telling
the truth yeah i have said that to him
and he can't get behind beyond the
college degree stuff in
that's the stopping point for him and
did you bring up
like i'm sure bob told you the same
story he told me
about working at los alamos lab and his
education at mit i did not tell him that
story
but it would not have mattered because
stan didn't hear any of that stuff
all the things about how does he go out
and know it's going to fly on wednesday
night and take friends out there three
weeks in a row and then record it
on video right doesn't want to hear that
one just didn't hear it
why not he'd already made up his mind
that's not good that's not scientific
and i can understand like uh my emails
and correspondences and texts are a
dump truck for conspiracy like every
everybody thinks i'm some [ __ ]
believer and they can just hit me with
like
[ __ ] 5g covid stuff and i'm like
jesus christ
so it's people that actually know me my
friends and george too
we're like the person that's hardest to
convince that your story
has validity we ask for documents from
military background we
we vet people right he vetted lazar i
vetted lazar it's not like we're sitting
here oh we want this to be true tell us
your story
but do you understand that's why the
skinwalker ranch thing does nothing for
me i understand
right yeah i ain't totally interested
yeah i just i don't
i don't see anything there yeah i see uh
a dead cow
yeah there were phd scientists on that
ranch
for 20 years some part of the time
working for the us government trying to
figure it out
they would have experiences they can't
document them
they realize that nobody's going to
believe it it was very frustrating but
they tried to look for a bigger picture
of what it was trying to teach them why
why is these performances and that's how
they consider
them like performances they're not just
ufos popping in here just because it's a
portal or something
they were showing glimpses of themselves
for a reason because
if they didn't want us to see them we
wouldn't see them it's like the tic tac
there's the tic tac sitting around it's
it's been there for a couple of weeks
zipping in and out we can't quite get a
radar
bearing on it and it's sitting there
waiting for fraber to come along and
then it kind of reacts
oh is there somebody else here and it
zips away you know
it knew that we were there given its
capabilities it wanted to be seen
but why that's the difficult thing is is
can you accept so
if this ufo thing is real and there are
these intelligent craft and stuff
can we accept that it is aware of us
that it is aware that we have cell
phones that it is aware
that we want to monitor it and if it's
highly advanced wherever it's from i
don't care if it's [ __ ] aliens or
again north korea i don't care who it is
right but if they're that advanced if
this technology if there's any weight to
it which there is
then we have to know that they are aware
of
us looking at them and that they can
work from a technologically more
advanced standpoint right
i mean i have to accept that skinwalker
all that it was hard for me when i when
i started
doing the film and working with george
on it it's hard for me where's the
concrete evidence i see command of favor
that's
concrete errors the documents that's
what he first showed me documents
documents
great that's hard evidence so i know and
it's hard to accept some of that but i'm
not going to exclude it like i didn't
exclude bob
i want to find out the truth i'm not
going to exclude it investigate the
unknown don't
no so the you know there might be some
scary explanations
ultimately that they live here that they
can see us
and read our thoughts and we're in the
shower and we're sleeping and they're
watching and they manipulate us
on a micro and macro scale that it's
their planet not ours that we're an
agricultural product that's scary
the other thing that's scary is what if
we are totally alone you know
that they're we're the only life in the
in anywhere that this the only inhabited
planet
some people believe that i i don't but
that's pretty scary too
because you look at how we take care of
ourselves and it's not very well
you know yeah
um it's the whole subject is such a
weird one because
you spend a lot of time on it and you
start thinking am i just
wasting my precious energy here
on nonsense like but then you hear
like one of the things that bob told me
that was so strange
was uh when we were doing the podcast he
was saying that they think that one of
them was really
old it was from an archaeological dig
and i was like well why are they leaving
spacecrafts around are they leaving
spacecrafts around so like go ahead let
them figure this [ __ ] out yes
yes you think that i think so like i
said
throw in the cell phone into the monkey
cage here help yourself knock yourself
out
and we see these displays you know if
they didn't want us to see them we
wouldn't they have stealth capability
we can see them right there and not see
them on radar we can see them on radar
but they're invisible
you know they you can only see them
sometimes through through thermal so as
our military
devices get better at detection ufo
sightings are going up and it's because
we now can look at them
purely through thermal heat signature
compared to just you know flying but
some of them don't
display a thermal heat signature
absolutely do some of them do and some
of them don't do they
they display different forms of
propulsion
i don't know don't know we'd have to it
seems
extremely varied you know is that
there's anything you can imagine and
more this cop
just called me a month ago and he's not
a ufo guy anything and he had an
encounter he claims
that it was so extraordinarily strange
like
non-aerodynamic something impossible
he saw something impossible they come in
all shapes and forms it's just that as
we look
more we're seeing more i think because
our technology is increasing
and maybe because our awareness also
we're starting to be more curious
our government and our scientists i
think the scientific community
should engage this topic you have stuff
to study now michio kaku famously
recently said the burden of evidence
about these not
being extraterrestrial craft is now on
the scientific community
because there's such a weight of
evidence now that there are craft
our government's working on it the
russians are working on it and the
chinese are working on it those that we
know of for sure
that's been told to me directly senator
reid had said that was one of the
reasons he started the program
because he's had indications that those
other governments are trying to
figure out the same stuff that we're
figuring out and if some of us
can master that technology the russians
get it the chinese get it before we do
it's it's we're in trouble or the aliens
come down and smack everybody around
so what do you what do you what do you
think man after kind of you know
doing three rounds on the ufo stuff you
know um
what do you think's up man i don't
that's the problem i don't
i don't i just sit back and i wait
you know i'm i'm i i think when you look
at fravor's
favors what what fravor saw clearly
there there's evidence there's there's
not just evidence that it was
jamming tracking there's them
trying to figure out what it is there's
the incredible rate of travel
where it can go from 60 000 feet to
above the surface in like literally a
second and they don't even know how fast
it really went because it takes a second
for the radar to
to register that's that alone is just
bonkers like what is that like what is
that and how do you dismiss that and no
sonic booms as an example so that would
a trans medium craft is one that goes
through
space air or c and it doesn't have the
same displacement
as you'd normally have that would be a
gravity-propelled craft no sonic booms
no splashes of water
um yeah so it's i so i'm just curious
where you know before you were
you've been back and forth on the topic
so how's george so if i get so
fed up with it sometimes i'm never going
to learn anything everybody's [ __ ]
crazy
well there's just so many people out
there that have an interest in
discussing it too
when they do these lectures they tour
and they do these ufo conferences
and they just get together with other
[ __ ] artists and they make a living
it does happen that's a part of the
problem so part of the problem is that
there's there's money to be made in this
and
you realize that when you interview
these so-called experts
when you sit down and talk to them a lot
of them are just they're knuckleheads
and they don't respond very well to
scrutiny
luckily he's a journalist journalist
with a day job and you know i'm also i'm
just a filmmaker not just a ufo
researcher you know
you're kind of obsessed let's be honest
i'm going to be completely honest i
am i'm i'm how do you not be how do you
not be i mean it's it's the one of the
most compelling subjects that the human
race has ever known
are we alone and if we're not alone is
is something
as advanced to us as we are to ants
you know and and that is obviously
there's if if you follow the string of
evolution things become more and more
complex and in the case of primates they
become more and more intelligent
more and more capable of manipulating
their environment so if we extrapolate
and we go a thousand years from now or
we take ourselves to a totally different
environment where you don't have the
same sort of
tooth and claw competition as you have
here on earth
i mean maybe they exist in some sort of
a planet with a completely different
ecosphere a completely different uh
series of of metals and and and
different propulsion systems get
invented first long before fire i mean
maybe they're just
messing with some stuff that's just very
different than us maybe they live in a
more stable environment where they don't
have to worry about asteroidal impacts
and they've had a steady chain of
evolution that's gone on for millions
of years i mean we don't we really don't
know just think about a civilization
that's so much as
a hundred years older than us right
especially now i think how far we've
come in 50 years i mean the stuff that
50 years ago a cell phone might be
considered witchcraft you know
and and the the rate of change is
exponential something 100 years or a
thousand years older than us
could have technology that's basically
magic and a million years
in terms of biological life on earth is
really nothing
it's nothing we haven't even been alive
for a million years humans haven't been
human for a million years
so just think what goes on a million
years from now
the other thing that always trips me out
is the archetypal alien
when you look at it it's like if you
took
cavemen or or you go back to chimps and
cavemen
and then humans you're seeing this
pattern of
the heads are getting bigger the muscles
are getting smaller the body's getting
less hairy well if you keep going what
do you get
you get an even bigger head and muscles
that are almost non-existent
these like like stick bodies but they
still
maintain that sort of iconic
primate shape they're kind of
primate-like
where they walk on two legs they have
two arms
they vary the amount of digits they have
on their fingers they have heads
that have predators eyes because the
eyes face forward
like ours like are we looking at what
always happens to life i mean
if if life exists the way it exists here
and that it always gets to some point
where some
really intelligent species starts to
manipulate its environment and then it
starts to look like that
where they develop technology where they
don't need
brute force anymore so their bodies
slowly but surely shrink
and and become something that's just
not reliant on a muscle strength but
rather
on telekinetic ability the ability to
express themselves without words and
thoughts i mean that's one of the things
that elon said
when he was talking about his neural
link which is
you know i mean if you want if there's a
[ __ ] alien on earth it's that guy
right there
and he's talking about putting some sort
of a device
into people's skulls where wires will go
to different parts of your brain and
you'll be able to
greatly improve your ability to access
information it will
increase your bandwidth of information
substantially and in his words
you'll be able to talk without using
words
now when you look at aliens the iconic
alien has this slit for a mouth
very little nose giant eyes and
an enormous head well if we
allow ourselves to become some hybrid or
some symbiotic
computer cyborg type thing isn't that
what we're gonna look like
aren't we gonna let me maybe those
things have weird skin because we
realize like you know regular skin kind
of sucks
it gets zits you get cancer you know
it's it's penetrable
they've already figured out a way to
make some sort of a hybrid of
spider silk and human skin that would be
bulletproof
i mean this is something that they've
they've done research on in a lab i mean
whether or not it actually gets to a
human body you know who knows but
when you look at those things when you
think of that
iconic alien shape it does remind us
in in or it reminds us of the process of
evolution
it looks like what we could be like it
causes a lot of people to wonder if they
are time travelers yeah that's us in the
future coming back to see when we
screwed up planet earth or something
like that
we could be or it just could be their
their
their life that's gone further than
where we are and they know the process
and that's how they were able to
confidently manipulate our genetics
they're like well they're going to get
there anyway
let's just step in and jack up the
process
maybe we don't have a million years
maybe because of where we live in terms
of our galaxy
i mean this is a legitimate shooting
gallery there's like some
stupid number like 900 000 near earth
objects that could end us you know
they're injecting miracle grow big hurts
yeah
the new crops come right yeah maybe
they're looking at this and like hey we
got to give these people steroids
like they're not growing quick enough
like let's get in there and and
get it so that they can legitimately
get to a point before they get hit and
we've been hit many times
while we're you know going through this
process but
get to a point where we can accelerate
their
their evolution i mean i don't know
i mean it sounds crazy but so do we
bullets sound crazy you know cars sound
crazy
electric cars sound crazier and it's
okay to talk about crazy things right i
mean we can
theorize for sure yeah a couple of
months ago nasa made an announcement
that they thought they had found
evidence
of or indications of a parallel universe
and um i don't know if you saw that
article or not but they thought that
i don't know if they're theorizing that
time
operated in the opposite direction in
that parallel universe now
get your head around that one benjamin
buttons you could go back in time you
become a baby
dark that's a great show in netflix oh
is it i saw the
uh um the image for it when i was
scrolling the other day straight up it's
like in a different language but they
translate so the lips move a little
differently
but man it is deep you have to have like
take notes as you watch it's about the
mobius loop of time with alternate
dimensions blew me the [ __ ] away
it's great it's great yeah it is
the ultimate who knows question but god
damn i wish more people from
s4 would come forth if bob really did
work with all those people and they
really were
briefed the same way he was if we could
get
more of those people to talk that would
be utterly fascinating
well your show has a big reach so maybe
this time somebody will hear it did
anybody
ever reach out to you that claimed to
also have worked with bob at s4 a bunch
yeah yeah
and and do you verify anyone no you know
they could not be verified and in fact i
think they were lying to me
um and bob shoots people down all the
time so that guy's [ __ ] standing on
ufo stage line
[ __ ] i mean you know no he hasn't
even he was hoping one other employee
would
um however i have had people that work
at area 51
confirm parts of bob's story one in
particular
saw him coming off the jet where he says
he saw him
coming off the janet flights i said will
you go on record with me that you
met bob there on the tarmac no
why everything we did there
was confidential we couldn't even tell
our wives
why would i go on record with you and if
he did go on record he'd probably get
harassed
or arrested or yeah he can't even tell
you what he ate for lunch out there
you know that so and one of the guys i
was really excited to talk with just
recently passed away he actually started
the bar that was at area 51 so everybody
told the bartender stuff he started as
a flower fund because no one would send
flowers to wives when people died out
there
but my point is people have come forward
to george to me
a lot of people are lying but it adds up
over time man
i got more than two dozen people who
have come to me with bits and pieces of
the story who had worked out at area 51
that i confirmed were out there
uh security people who had seen a a disc
uh
under a a tarp in a in a hangar um
different people had worked there at
different times 50s 60s 70s and 80s who
had little pieces of the story
not to confirm bob and then there was
one that i pursued i i
don't know if you want to keep going on
this but i pursued this guy
i was trying to find in the early 90s
people who were in a position to know
about what goes on out there and i found
one and he had he had been active in the
nuclear weapons program he had worked
for eg
g he had eg g had the contract to manage
area 51 from the beginning all the way
through the first 30 or 40 years of it
and so i started basically stalking the
guy
one of his sons was a state senator and
he had told me he confided to me that
you got to ask my dad about
ufos and aliens and another son had been
an fbi agent so i stalked the guy
introduced myself there were a couple of
public events where i would just show up
and he finally got confident enough in
me to invite me to his home
and he start gets out these scrapbooks
and he's showing me these stories and
clippings and photos from the nuclear
weapons program
and i'm watching and taking notes and
stuff and suddenly he closes the book
and he goes
you're not here to talk about this
nuclear weapons are you i said no not
really
and his wife walks in and she says oh
you're not going to tell him that stuff
are you
and then he started telling me and then
over the course of two years
i would meet with him have a cup of
coffee somewhere i couldn't take notes i
couldn't record anything
but he told me the story now this guy
actually is someone that you've
had reference to on your show remember
annie jacobson their book about eric
yeah well it's the same guy but the
story that he told me was different than
what he told her
he said that they eventually told me
that they had a live alien out there
that i could not go public with this
until after he died that they
um that they had craft that it was in a
special
spot originally was at indian springs
which is now creech air force base
and then it was moved area 51 when 51
became active
and then there was a very small group
that tried to analyze this stuff they
didn't know
where it was from they didn't know how
we obtained it he said this thing was
alive
and and that they eventually were able
to communicate with us
and told me that he was going to make a
videotape and he was going to
make it available so that after he died
i could have it well suddenly
two or three years later he totally
changes his story
what had happened was there was a
congressional investigator
his name was richard damato and he
worked for senator robert byrd
and he oversaw black budget projects and
he got onto this
ufo story from whitley strieber and so
he was assigned find out what the deal
is so he went around the country
talked to different researchers and came
to me and wanted to know about
area 51 and lazar so i told him a story
and i told him about this guy
and he got permission for this guy to
violate his security oaths and talk to
him about it
and they had multiple conversations and
they went to the founders of eg g the
company and
and uh it became a dead end but after
that congressional inquiry this guy
completely changed his tune
so he made up this story which is the
one that you heard from andy jacobson
that
what crashed at roswell was a russian
technology
a nazi technology flown by the russians
containing uh little concentration camp
victims
who'd been experimented on by dr mengele
completely
ridiculous you know story um but i think
he got scared
he was a real guy in a real position to
know
and had shared with his family some of
this information
i think the story that he told me um was
legit
but if he made the tape which i think he
did i didn't get it
how much time has been wasted talking
about [ __ ]
yeah in this subject oh 100 centuries
centuries that's part of the problem
isn't it people just make
[ __ ] up yeah and the more fanciful and
ridiculous
um the bet the better unfortunately
people pay more
to hear that and consume it i had an
operation one time after the lazar thing
somebody who was targeting me and he had
other people helping him
that convinced me that he had worked out
there with live aliens
and i'm getting letters from his
supposedly written by his neighbors
hey you got to check this guy out doctor
i'll just say x
he was taken away by armed security in
the middle of the night i think he has
something to do with aliens
and from out of the blue then suddenly i
am
at a planetarium event and i'm going to
speak about ufos at some
event at this community college and the
guy shows up in a men's room
hey my name is dr x standing there at
the urinal
you're not doing a story about me are
you so no who are you what
this was a concerted effort to get me to
believe that he had worked out there and
it went on for
a couple of years and of course it was
complete [ __ ] when i finally did
dig into his background i was able to
document where he had worked and what
he'd been doing through most of his life
and
it was just like a fantasy role-playing
thing at least i hope it was
so it's really hard to find credible
people i'm super lucky to have jordan as
a mentor because when i go left
and i should be going right he's like
i've already gone you know left
a decade ago idiot you know check this
out so but i don't think a lot of people
have
um somebody like george who can tell you
what the [ __ ] is and prove it to you
before you go down the wrong path
so you're right this field of research
or whatever
it's filled with curiosity that's the
good thing human desire
everybody everybody in the world has a
ufo story and knows somebody else who
does
so it's a common link between us all but
it is filled with charlatans kooks
freaks and schizophrenic sure you could
say that
mainly it's filled with good intended
people who are curious too
but having people like george over 35
years
you know not make a major mistake report
the news
break stories open i'm grateful for that
because it makes my job a lot easier
i can filter the [ __ ] much faster so
i'd say yes it sucks there's a lot of
kooks and crazy people in this field
but mainly there's a lot of curious
people who are good intended i'm
encouraged by what's happened in the
last couple of years i mean not only the
information coming out of the government
because it's a little more solid than
what you typically get from ufo people
but also by the new wave of people who
are now interested because of your show
because of what's happened since the new
york times story there's a whole new
generation of people who are suddenly
waking up and paying attention to it
and are reading all the books and trying
to figure this stuff out for themselves
and also going through the process of
separating wheat from chaff
i'm glad to see that there's some new
energy in it and
ultimately i hope that those folks if
not me will be able to
get some answers on this someday well as
preposterous as we would like
if we want to sleep well at night we'd
like to pretend that it's impossible it
doesn't make any sense
just when you look up you look up you
see
infinity you see hundreds of
billions of stars just in this galaxy
and this is one of hundreds of billions
of galaxies
of course there's something out there
it's really just of course
it's not if it's not do you think
it's of course of course there's no
[ __ ] way there's not
whatever happened here that created us
is likely to have happened in an
infinite number of different forms
all throughout the cosmos the the real
question is can they come here
and the real question is if they have
come here
what where where from and how and and
and how much how much interest do they
have in us and
how long have they been paying attention
to us and how much of the ancient
scriptures
were really about that like you know i
mean everybody [ __ ] all over zechariah
sitchin's interpretations of the
sumerian text
but what if he's right like what if he's
right what if the anunnaki really were
creatures from another planet that came
here and manipulated
primate dna to create people and when
you see those
those ancient sumerian
those clay tablets that were created
where you see like a
large god-like creature with a humanoid
monkey creature with a tail sitting on
its lap and this tiny thing
and the the image of the solar system
with the correct amount of planets and
the sun in the center and all
and you realize this was made 6 000
years ago
like what is that like as much as people
love to mock
you know his his books what is that
like what are what are these things what
is this i mean obviously
we lost some technologies because i mean
i'm not an architect but the stones that
are pressed together almost like they're
molded all around the world
in these like pyramid structures and
washers you know
it's my understanding that we we cannot
create
that now today at with as such
perfection
that's incredible if that's true is
there a technology that we
have figured out and then lost and we're
just in a cycle of that
or was there intervention well it's most
likely
there's been some catastrophes that set
humanity back
there's a lot of evidence that points to
that there's a lot of evidence that
points to this period
i mean and graham hancock and randall
carlson have done an amazing job of
illuminating that
on this podcast if you go back and
listen to those episodes
there's real physical evidence of
asteroid
impacts of meteor meteors hitting earth
somewhere in the neighborhood of 12 000
years ago and that is also
when you go to this this period
of construction there's there's things
that look like they could be older
that are built differently particularly
like in egypt than a lot of other parts
of the world
and then you find this layer of tr
what's it called tritonite trinidad
what is it trinity trinity trinity this
nuclear glass
they find that stuff all over when they
do core samples and it's always around
12
000 years right and then the the
almost uh instant changing of the ice
age
the floods that followed i mean all the
stuff that's detailed in the bible
like the floods and noah that coincides
they believe
with these impacts and that these
impacts happened and it
radically changed the climate killed an
enormous
amount of people probably set technology
back thousands of years
and then we are the product of this sort
of slow reboot
could there have been survivors that a
small group of them that survived
and now are more advanced than us it's a
breakaway civilization
also an interesting question a lot of
people have explored
i don't know yeah who knows it's it's
one of those
again time-wasting [ __ ] where
you just yeah
you could go down the rabbit hole at the
end of time it you know it's
central human kind of questions where
are we on the food chain
why are we here what what's the reason
for this uh maybe
and what is our reaction going to be if
something visits i mean if something
does really hover over the
if trump wins the re-election and
they're like enough
some gigantic you know city-sized
ufo hovers over the white house and we
realize like oh
okay i know people say we're ready we
want to know we're ready we can handle
it look at look how they're handling
covet
you know look at how freaked out people
are over this we're not ready for
anything
maybe if i saw that what you're
describing i mean i'd love to see a
mothership
you know if i ever saw something like
that like val kilmer in that movie of
the roller rink if i ever saw that
i'd probably just be like cool job
done that was fun studying that you
would oh man you'd be like we gotta get
a camera crew out there immediately
netflix i got something you'd be driving
there with your window rolled down
screaming out the window to see it man
honestly i just i think it would freak
me out more than anything it's like oh
[ __ ]
it's probably different seeing it than
hearing all these stories from people
which i'm
i'm open to everybody's contacting
that's fine yeah but seeing it yourself
i yeah i don't know how
i would react but maybe i'd just be like
it would be like you're on drugs i think
i think you'd be like you're on
psychedelic drugs i think
seeing it would would shift your
perception so radically
i bet your your brain would overload i
bet it would be really hard to wrap your
head around
just seeing it qualified reporters you
know like policemen this is one i keep
bringing up this guy
man his mind when he saw this impossible
thing and i i believe him
he he did see what he what he said he
tries to describe it in terms
that make sense to him but he struggles
because it was so
odd the crap it was just so odd so i
don't know if you ever see one let me
know though because
i'll let everybody know believe me you
would yeah i would yeah
yeah i haven't seen [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
like the inspector crusoe in my back
turn all the time he'll probably see it
before us but
maybe well it would be really
interesting they're like george you've
been looking for a long time
we'd like to talk to you i've wondered
you know what would happen if
even less than aliens or whoever they
are if uh if somebody were to
say all right we're going to show you
we're going to open the hangar doors you
can go in and see the sport model
that lazar touched right you can never
report on it again
would you take that offer probably yeah
i think i would too i'd shut my mouth
i just wouldn't want to see it i mean
selfishly and i'm admitting this
because you ain't gonna find out if i
say no [ __ ] right
if i say no i have to tell everybody
well then they're not gonna show me
anyway that's right
and if i do show it and i tell them then
they're not gonna i tell people they're
not gonna show me anything else
yeah it's um it's a hard one do you have
family members that you trust
you know somebody that you trust that uh
has reported something like that to you
no no no nothing i could think of
not like a good friend yeah
trying to remember
no one nothing nothing where you know
there's
there's things that people could get
wrong right you know there's
experimental aircrafts like i remember
when the first time i saw stealth
bombers after september 11th we were
working
out in palmdale doing fear factor and
that's near edwards air force base
and uh i saw one of those things fly by
i was like holy [ __ ]
it's the [ __ ] it's the jedi's or
something i mean it just looked like it
looked like stormtroopers like it didn't
look like something from this world when
you see that
have you seen a stealth fight it's crazy
man you look at one of those things like
that's a ufo like i felt like we were in
some sort of strange
movie a star wars movie it was wild
seeing that thing fly across the sky i
was like wow
but i knew what it was you know i think
if i really saw an actual ufo i bet
i bet your brain would play all kinds of
tricks on you in terms of perception
and trying to interpret it especially if
it's a very quick thing
it was like you would roll that through
your memory your member would [ __ ] with
you all kinds of different ways
you would have all kinds of weird
distorted ideas of what you saw and how
you saw it
what it exactly looked like it would be
so hard to get a super
accurate like recallable memory
of what that thing is some of the most
interesting ufo cases are
where high strangeness is mixed in so
it's not only seeing the craft but then
a lot of really weird beautiful stuff
like you're on
mushrooms or something goblins
like in a shooting gallery the
hopkinsville case or
you know other kinds of strange
creatures and phenomena um
maybe it comes with the territory here's
what i noticed
someone will call me and they say i
don't want to be known i just want
to tell somebody oh you seem accessible
let me tell you my story
don't report on okay cool got it they'll
tell me they saw a ufo like a disc
or something big not like a ball of
light something big
and i'll be like okay cool is that it is
that where your story ends and and
almost every time there's something much
more personal
much more strange that occurred
almost every time so you have to imagine
people are okay with reporting ufos to
you or whatever they can say i saw what
i think ufo
but a lot of people aren't telling the
full story until you really dig and find
out because it makes them uncomfortable
time distortions creatures beings
so i don't know man if any of that's
true you know if these if these
experiences go beyond the hardware of
the saucers this sort of thing
then it gets more complicated um
and on that note gentlemen we've passed
the three hour mark believe it or not
[ __ ] yeah
thanks for having me joe my pleasure
thank you for everything you've done
over all the years you've made a
gigantic impact on on me and my
perceptions of
this whole phenomenon and uh i think in
the ufo community at large
and thank you also jeremy for your
documentaries what brought me around
thanks joe that's awesome man thank you
all right well thank you everybody
[Music]
[Music]
bye